e
my desk all of a sudden stops
starts I don't know what this is all
right let me get this let me get this
started first of all we all rise and
salute the
flag yes please join with me and a
pledge to our flag I pledge Al to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation indivisible liy and justice for
all thank you if you if you wish to
testify on the this on and with the two
one of the either of the two bills that
they're taking up you have to fill out a
pink
card let me see this is on
1513 there
recognizes well let's first I'm going to
open the hearing on House Bill
1513 relative to the board of directors
of the peas Development Authority and
the chair recognizes repr representative
Mai is the sponsor of the
Bill thank you Mr chairman the Ste
members of resources and Recreation and
development for the record my name is uh
Mark makoni I represent the good people
of Carol County uh District
8 and I'm here today to introduce 1513
relative the uh to the board of
directors of the peas Development
Authority uh for a little bit of
background uh a somewhat similar Bill
had come to Public Works and highways uh
last year and uh when we were taking up
the capital budget uh I chair uh Public
Works and highways we had a robust
conversation which I'm sure we will have
again today on this subject uh we had
met
afterwards uh with the um with the PE uh
Development Authority and looking at
what might be the uh best solution uh
for them going forward on
appointments and uh that's that was is
what the emphasis is of uh this proposal
and how I came to be tied to this uh the
peas Development Authority is of course
you know dedicated to the people and
economy of New Hampshire it's no single
town it's an economic engine for the
entire state which is how it came to be
sitting in our committee before um it
you know has Parts in the airport the
port authority and the trade
Port I um I am joined here today by the
chairman Steve Dupri who um who we've
had lengthy conversations previous this
to and I'm going to tee it up for him to
come forward and say why um this
legislation is important to his
authority uh so with that um I'm happy
to take uh any questions and uh Mr
chairman any uh questions from the
members of the
committee you raising your hand or
you're
wav representative Lon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
what
specific uh policy changes at peas do
you think would result by the board um
appointees being appointed by the
governor as opposed to local thank you
communities I appreciate the question
and there'll be there'll be others to
speak to this but um the the the way the
membership is is uh at this point in
time uh there has been a history
let let me start by saying this is a
state facility not just a just not one
town it has everything to do with the
economic uh prosperity of the state but
unfortunately a town um was um was
leaning on representation from their
town to think first for their town as
opposed to what's best for the authority
and best for the state and it's my
understanding that they're trying to um
while localities should be involved in
the
conversation but they should be part of
a of the higher uh cause which is a uh
which is the economic uh development of
the entire State and there's there have
been issues to my understanding to the
other
way any other questions uh by members of
the committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you represent
representative uh Dennis
Malloy thank you very
much thank you very much Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
I am Dennis Malloy I represent Greenland
and
Rye in the Sea Coast
Area and I have written testimony that
you have in front of you but I'm not
going to just read that I have a few
comments that I'd like to make and uh
set the table for uh our perspective on
this green
is a town that contains uh one of the
major arteries that feeds peas um and
there are thousands of people every day
twice a day that drive up and down um
Highway 33 through our town and we
support that uh we are in in complete
support of all the development that peas
has brought to the area and we want to
help that it's been important for us to
uh be in the room and at that table with
some uh degree of of uh authority to
comment and to receive comments about
what Greenland can do and uh can be to
help uh the peas Development Authority
meet its goals we understand the
economic uh engine of this and that's
why we are uh speaking today about
maintaining some
local um interest on appointments to
that board as we all hear on the floor
of the house and throughout New
Hampshire that local
control is very important to us we
thrive on that we've built the state on
that
premise and this is one of those
opportunities to live up to that
premise and keep that Spirit of
local control is not the right word but
local influence local um information
local give and take on these important
issues we understand peas is a huge
Economic Development factor for the
state it sits on uh the property of
Portsmouth sits on the property of
Newington Greenland abuts
it it affects fects Rye affects
Newcastle it affects
statam it affects uh many many towns all
positively we believe it's important for
uh our local officials to have
some say in that and that's really the
um the purpose of my being here today to
uh um impress upon you that point point
and I'll be happy to and I know we have
several other people here so I I I'll
just leave it with that I'll be happy to
take any questions if you have
any any questions by by me
representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question can um maybe you
could provide us some examples of the
influence um the the repres joint
representative between Greenland and
Newington have had on the on the
committee I've not been a part of those
conversations when we uh wrote the Bill
to create
this uh we purposely set this up so that
the the select Boards of
both Greenland and Newington would make
that appointment there's no political
appointment here uh at at this level
it's the local folks and I know there
are people here today from uh Newington
and others that may be able to better
answer that question uh than than I can
uh so if you would allow me to uh pass
on that one I I'd be happy to thank
you anyone
else
oh my
apologies thank you Mr chairman um thank
you representative Malloy for coming in
and
testifying um so I was looking at the
makeup of the um Development Authority
and I just wanted to know what kinds of
decisions does this Authority make on
behalf of the towns yeah it's similar to
uh uh representative Darby's question
and as I said earlier I there are people
here from the towns who can answer that
directly would
be they're in the decision-making
process I I'm not uh and we set it up
purposely that way so if you again and
indulge me in that I'd be happy to pass
that to others okay thank you for taking
my
question any other questions by members
of the
committee thank you very much thank you
very much for your
time chair recognizes uh Steve Dupri
chair of the PE Development
Authority morning Madame chairman
members of the committee uh I always
like to start by saying thank you for
your service you're worth every penny
those of you who know me know that I
served in this body 50 years ago uh I
just look younger than I am I am the
chair of the peas Development Authority
we don't take a position on how you
folks decide to make up our membership
uh but I will give you my personal
opinion and tell you about the issue
we're trying to solve first in answer to
the question what do we decide we
actually decide on every contract every
proposal for development at peas every
proposal for use of our ports and
harbors which are pretty
extensive uh and it's a big job um I was
the governor's appointment when I was
asked to serve I said why me I'm from
conquer I don't go to Portsmouth I don't
do any business I don't know the players
I never go out on the ocean I don't even
eat much seafood and uh I don't even
know the players he said perfect you're
just what we want um here's the so we
have to
decide um we have everything from people
who want to expand businesses over there
sigu for example is in the middle and we
lease space to them uh to whether we're
going to allow cruise ships to come into
the port that's being rebuilt in
Portsmouth it's a very wide
ranging organization it was the first
base closed in this country under bra
you remember when P closed it has I
would argue been the single most success
ESS F Redevelopment of a port in the
country or base it works very well here
are a few overlying facts we don't
actually Own It We Own It subject to an
FAA Grant to us when the defense
department gave up the property they of
course have a recall provision if we
were in a war and they needed to take
over the entire property they
could then it went to the FAA the FAA
then granted it and deed it if you will
to the p Development Authority subject
to the right that we or subject to the
responsibility that we have to follow
all of their mandates so we get a number
of mandates that we don't have any
choice in we also have gotten a lot of
federal money that also uh impacts us so
every time we think we want to do
something it's a very laborious process
for example I suggested why why don't we
have a private operator or let the
National Guard run the airport why now
that it's developed sort of we have a
few Lots left why have us and the FAA
came up from Boston and said you can't
do that you must continue to run it I
said well what if we decided we don't
want to uh they immediate response was
every Community that's in the area would
lose its eligibility for any Federal
grant of any kind which was kind of
threatening so we have a lot of
strictures on us here is the issue that
we're trying to solve and I would
recommend you kill this bill I have
great friends the mayor of Portsmouth
was calling me and saying we want to
have our local control and there's a
makeup the governor appoints somebody
the speaker appoints somebody the towns
have a representative the uh county has
a representative it's a great group they
work hard uh people change in and
out I would recommend you kill the bill
but I will tell you the problem we're
trying to solve if you look at the
enabling legislation it says every vote
we
take every member has to consider three
things the impact on the surrounding
communities the impact on the region or
benefit or detriment and the impact
benefit or detriment to the state
coldbrook Handover North Conway
Kean there are a couple issues that come
up from time to time whether it's Air
Cargo or whether it's anything else
where not with bad
intentions perhaps not understanding
that we're a body itic which is subject
to exercising our fiduciary duty where
the local appointed representatives were
directed by the municipal governing
Authority on how they were to vote on an
issue and that was brought to the
board's attention saying I have a letter
from my governing Authority that tells
me that notwithstanding my obligation to
consider the impact on the area or not
withstanding my obligation to consider
the benefit or impact to the state I
cannot consider those I must do as I
have been directed that is directly
incompatible with the enabling
legislation and with our responsibility
in fact we showed it to our legal
councel who reviewed it and reviewed it
with the attorney general saying that's
not permissible it's not if the governor
sent me a letter telling me how to vote
on an issue I would resign because they
do not have that Authority it runs
contrary to the whole establishment of
the authority there are some issues that
get very emotional particularly for the
most affected communities how many
flights a day and who's going to how
many trucks you know we have a lot of
users go right through Greenland for
example noise over Ry there are lots of
issues and there's no question the most
adjacent communities are the most
affected but when you tell a member they
must vote a certain way that puts not
only that member in a bad position it
prevents The Authority from doing what
the statute says we are to do which is
to consider all three so I think there's
a simple solution simpler solution to
this it's important for the communities
that get appointing authority to make
that that appointment but I think if we
if you decide to get rid of this bill
which I would recommend that we come
back with another bill that simply makes
it
clear that no appointing authority
whether it's the governor it's the town
of Newington it's the Str stord County
appointee shall direct any member on how
to vote because it's directly contrary
to how we do things in New Hampshire and
it also would be an abdication of their
responsibility under the statute and I
also think if you look at the appointing
authority how you can be removed I
actually serve at the pleasure of the
governor um but most of the appointments
say you can be removed for cause we need
to make it very clear that just because
a representative appointed from straford
County or from Portsmith or from one of
the communities doesn't vote the way the
governing body the selectman of the city
council would like them to that absent
bad faith or absent gross negligence
that's not cause because we need people
to exercise their independent judgment
you know I get the question all the time
what good is peas doing for Kean what
Good's PE doing for North Conway
what good is pe's doing for wrench and I
know let's be honest the burden falls on
the local communities but so has an
enormous benefit it has been a true
economic engine so that's everything I
know I I would recommend you kill this
bill it will preserve the right of the
communities to make their appointments
and that the sponsors or someone else
come back with a new bill that simply
strengthens the duties that says no
appointing authority whether it's the
governor the Speaker of the House house
the town of Newington Portsmouth shall
direct their member how to vote and
voting contrary to that Town's or
appointing Authority's wishes is not
good cause just cause for removable
absent bad fith we cannot be in a
position where we have members come in
who say I feel constrained not to
consider the impact on the county or on
the state because I've been directed by
my governing Authority whether that's
the governor telling me what what to do
or town selectman or the city council
I'd be glad to answer any
questions any any questions by members
of the
committee representative
har thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question you um this is a
board of directors do you have bylaws
yes we do have a followup a followup
could you not make that same statement
in the bylaws that you'd want us to pass
a bill to say have you looked into that
um we definely could have and our bylaws
talk about our fiduciary duty to abody
politic but when an appointing authority
tells a member you shall vote that way
they obviously feel constrained and I
think we just want to make
sure that whoever anybody who has the
authority to appoint somebody doesn't
also think they also have the authority
to tell them how to vote good thank
you any other questions by members of
the
committee representative of Derby thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question you mentioned um uh including
remove for cause um and one of the um
one of the positions of the seven does
have removed for cause are you are you
suggesting all of them including the
three appointed by you know there's one
by the governor one by the by the
speaker of the house and so on all of
them should that would be fine okay uh
right now it's only straford County and
the municipal appointed if there were
some definition cause can't be I
disagree with how you voted
cause should be you know negligence
gross negligence abdication of Duty not
showing up for the meetings you know uh
but we what we're trying to do is make
sure that every decision we make
considers all three of what you told us
we had to consider benefit and impact on
surrounding communities benefit and
impact on region and let's not forget
benefit and impact on the
state representative donelly thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um in the in the past ear year
has there been any
uh vote that actually uh said look we
don't want the following thing and it
did impact the state I'm trying to
understand the well I'll give you an
example there was for a brief time a
proposal for Air Cargo now keep in mind
that the last time I went to peas we
were flying strategic bombers with
nuclear tipped weapons on them so I
think anything's an improvement over
that but um uh Air Cargo would have a
significant impact on those in the
flight path okay uh there are benefits
to the state for Air Cargo tremendous
benefits uh there benefits to the
airport in terms of fees because we
spend a 100% of our funds that we make
from the golf course and rent to keep up
the airport I keep going why don't we
take that money and do something else
with it we're not allowed to by the FAA
in fact we can't take the profits we
make at the airport and use them to help
the ports I mean that's how strict the
restrictions are on us so uh a good
example uh that proposal died uh I think
a majority of the board didn't think Air
Cargo is appropriate at peas for a
number of reasons but that's a great
case where Air Cargo could be a benefit
to the state but a detriment to some
degree to the impacted communities if
you tell a member they may not consider
the benefit to the state you're
basically taking away or trying to limit
them from exercising there for Deary
Duty which we just want to make sure we
make we're happy to hear from everybody
I think we have a very good track record
I've only been on this board for a
couple years of listening to everybody
on every issue and inviting people in to
talk to the staff with professionals and
not hiding any disagreements or disputes
and just trying to do the best job we
can that's fairest to everybody and
there's
always except when we approve a road
race use of the roads inside everybody's
always unhappy about some decision we
have to
make but that Air Cargo would be a good
example um you know for a while there
was a debate over how many free based
operators I'll give a good example FBO
is a freebased operator we've had one
there uh Port City air for many years
they took over from PanAm there was a
proposal by another group millionaire to
do one I think that's sort of gone away
but the FAA I said well why don't we
avoid this dispute and just say we only
want one FBO that's
illegal if 10 freebased operators come
in and meet the requirements we have to
let 10 in even though we think that's a
terrible idea personally I think it' be
a terrible idea but we have so many
strictures placed on us by the
FAA by the Department of Defense that it
really does limit some of our
discretion so I'm trying to make your
life easy you should tell everybody
who's here worried that we want to take
away that we don't leave that a point in
Authority let's work on how we make it
clear that no appointing authority shall
direct a member how to
vote representative love it for question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my
question if you were to put the Hat on
the representatives the representatives
from the local communities what do you
think that they're major or over the
years over the the past couple of years
their most significant concerns have
been um well with the cargo air
particularly everybody was going to be
at the South End of the runway they
didn't want to be in a noise pattern
that's very legitimate different from
the state's concern which would in hear
it on this big fight where lobbyists got
millions of dollars so I'm glad they're
thriving to lobby for against the FBO
that was applying it was environmental
concerns and those are I think still
working their way through the court even
though the original right of Entry is
what we call permission to start to
investigate a site has expired but we
know there are going to be more FBO
applications so um I think those have
been the two sort of hottest issues uh
frankly there have been issues
surrounding Sig hour uh which needs to
expand because of that large government
contract um we've had issues in the past
interestingly all the people who have
Office Buildings or any building over
there they don't own that why don't they
own it because they lease it why do we
not let them own it because the FAA
won't because the FAA has a right to
take every piece of that land back so we
give them long-term leases uh but we do
not have the right to actually sell a
piece of property per se a lot of people
don't realize
that or
followup thank you can you just really
quickly give me a an update on how the
surrounding communities around peas are
have addressed or are dealing with the p
issue um that's a great
question remember we we're we're limited
amount of time I'm trying to help you to
kill the bill here folks so everybody
can go home so here's
the you're talking to a guy who took his
last science course as a senior in high
school I'm a liberal arts history kind
of guy but here's the problem there's P
everywhere over there
um anytime there is a project it's a
concern um under the transfer from the
Air Force to the FAA to us somebody with
great foresight and I think it was
somebody in Governor Greg's office
because this happened on his watch
trying to imagine the Future made it
very clear that the Air Force owns that
liability so one of the things we have
to be very very careful with is not
doing anything that would allow the
United States Air Force to say you've
assumed that
liability um and I'll give you an
example of that we have a development
that would require removal of a
discontinued fuel line that the Air
Force had and to give permission to do
that to the private entity that's going
to build a building there they wanted
the Air Force wanted this private
developer who would never have deep
enough Pockets to solve the Pas issue to
assume liability and we wouldn't let
that happen we said that's a deal killer
we have to do it so ultimately what I
believe is going to happen is the United
States Air Force is going to be the
primary party responsible for cleaning
that up nationally again from the
briefings we've gotten on a pentagon
level they have this problem not only at
peas but lots of places
and they've been in my opinion this is
just me this is not the official
position of the peace Development
Authority they have been kicking the can
down the road and avoiding the issue and
thank goodness we have Portsmouth and
Newington and Ry and Greenland and
straford County and the state of New
Hampshire pushing hard on this issue
because it has to be addressed it is
their liability they are going to have
to address it and these communities and
P are pushing for a solution But
ultimately going to be the Air Force
it's going to be we don't know whether
it's a $300 million cleanup or a billion
doll cleanup at this point but we just
know it's a horrific problem and we're
being very careful to make sure the
state of New Hampshire does not assume a
liability that belongs to the federal
government thank you very much seeing no
more further questions not asking for
any either thank you kill the bill kill
the Bill thank you very much thank
you uh
Mar who's representing Newton uh is it
new yeah Newington
yeah uh please I can't read your writing
sorry please identify Martha Roy Town
Administrator town of Newington
representing the board of Selectmen you
all have uh at your desk a letter from
the board they are in opposition to this
bill to briefly speak to a few things
that have come up specifically
representative litz comments or
questions regarding past the town of
Newington is very concerned about the
past contamination that came from the
peas Development Authority uh area that
was due to firefighting foam being
released by the
USAF and we are now experiencing it in
our wells all over
town so in that regard there's a serious
concern about what happens and what is
allowed to be developed right over the
the aquifers that service the town of
Newington in addition I'll just say that
um three of the seven votes on this
Authority are for Portsmouth Newington
and Greenland just three of them so the
majority still stands with the governor
and
counsel and
also um different than many other State
Properties the town and cities provide
police fire and Public Works Services
the Newington Police Department uh is in
charge of the the policing of the
Newington half of the PDA Portsmouth
their half Public Works and fire as well
I'm glad to answer any
questions just one fast one uh do they
are you compensated for for uh that
those Services yes
absolutely any other questions by
members of the board board yeah of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
John
wordell represent himself
good morning and thank you uh quick
reference to the past there is no
solution that anyone's really aware of
at this point so it's in our wells it's
in our water the US Air Force monitors
it for us lets us know when it's at a
dangerous level then if at that point
you change your water system you go to
town city water or you put filters on so
there's no solution that we're aware of
yet uh I commend Mr dpri for agreeing
that this is a build that should be
killed uh it really rests local control
and REM moves it to the state so again
I'm very happy to see that he's in favor
of it I would point out that there's a
long history of the peace Development
Authority being very successful it
really is this he says an economic
engine for the region I think with
reference to the individual cases he
mentioned those are very recent and I
would look at those in the history of
the PDA there have been so many projects
that have come before the PDA that
everyone has approved it's only these
last couple projects the F ba fixed Base
operator um and the other one that the
towns in the area have objected to so I
think that's reasonable and then the
other one was the flights going over the
other end of the airport I think you're
going to expect a reasonable amount of
of objections from local communities
they really impact them
significantly I would agree that there
should be something in the documents as
you said Mr Arby that points out as Mr
Bri said as well that the towns have no
mandate in terms of how their
individuals vote but to your point Mr
Derby it should be that all members of
the PDA can be removed for M feance or
something as opposed to just a strap of
rep so very good point that you pick
though again I thank you for looking at
this bill I agree with the pr it should
be killed so thank
you is there any questions for members
of the of the uh the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
and
Emily
selli
yes in a name like Ren Zulu I should
have been able to read that good morning
I am uh here to speak in opposition of
this bill I have lived in New inton now
for 10 years and am pretty involved in
local politics there um New Hampshire
Prides itself on empowering local
citizens to be involved with its
government um as uh Dennis Malloy had
pointed out I think that is a
Cornerstone of our
uh State um on the way in I was
commenting I you know I remember coming
here in fourth grade right um and and I
think that that speaks volumes in terms
of um having empowering citizens to be
involved um this bill as proposed does
the opposite by allowing the governor
who whoever that may be and the
executive Council to determine who
represents our citizens at the peas
development Authority the PDA has been a
successful board and has created a great
Economic and Business Hub and therefore
I would ask the committee to oppose this
Bill thank you any questions by members
of the committee seeing none thank you
very much that is all of the uh that is
all of the pink cards and no one else
wishes to testify I will close the hear
excuse me I did put a card up
are you
goodan oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry how did I get somehow got into a
wrong pile inini my
apologies morning thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee um I actually
like to thank uh chairman duri for being
here as well and speaking I think uh he
shed a lot of light on where uh his
feelings on this and I'm here to speak
uh in agreement with him that I think
this bill as it stands uh should be
killed and um sounds like there's
probably definitely room for the PDA and
our local communities to all come
together maybe enhance our communication
a little bit um in any any different
facets but uh again my name is Brian
srini I'm a resident of Newington I'm
here to uh speak in opposition to that
business
as a lifelong resin of the SE Coast I've
seen firsthand the evolution of peas
from a Strategic Air Command base into
the thriving business and Commercial uh
development that it is today uh in fact
like many in the area and throughout the
state I believe what's taken place at
P's now International Trade Port uh over
the past 30 plus years is a true success
story in Economic Development none of
that success happened by accident for
sure and it came about through through a
lot of hard work by many people over the
years um but and uh much of which was
led and guided by the PDA and the
various board members in that time and
again over the years a big credit um and
a big reason why is the composition of
that board and um I think that that's
integral to have state government
involvement the governor and the council
house Speaker Senate President but just
as importantly some local community
input as those communities are are
directly affected but I also appreciate
what chairman duy said that the PDA is
does not work for the the seast it's
truly a state organization entity and I
do appreciate that but this is how it
was set up 30 years ago I think the
results of um PS and the PDA speak for
itself in those 30 years um and again I
just would uh like to thank you for your
time and and encourage you to uh
uh vote this bill down thank you very
much any questions by members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you and I apologize for no
problem for missing the card
uh I will close the hearing on uh House
Bill
1513 I'll pass the gavl over to the vice
chair for the house bill
1554 the oh let himem
it give me a chance to work my I'll open
the hearing on House Bill 1554 relative
to certified C maintenance program
reporting give me a chance to get
down the chairman is getting ready I
think the members have at their place
amendments proposed by the chair to
1554 here
your she want she's available if you
want Darlene force is darling force is
available if the committee needs to ask
any questions during our before we close
this hearing um this is a hearing on a
your main
Amendment and as
the as representative
Rulo moves to get to the speaker table
we'll have representative rulu speak on
his non gerine Amendment
first
representative Rula yes thank you Mr
chairman it's kind of tough working my
way back down here let I'm so
comfortable up
there members of the committee I am Andy
Rulo I'm representing at the town of
Hudson I wish to introduce a non gerain
amendment number
0967 the intent of this amendment is to
give the Department of Environmental
Services the authority to representative
can I interrupt you I apologize the one
I got in front of me says 0969
H oh
that's you're
right
I'm not a good typist as
so it is such the intent of the
amendment is to give the Department of
Environmental Services the authority to
regulate The Cutting of native aquatic
vegetation in New Hampshire's Lakes up
until a short time ago it was assumed
that Dees had that Authority Under The
Dredge and Phil statutes chapter
482a now Dees is concerned that the
present Dron Phil statute may not
be may not have that Authority Under the
present uh pres regen Phil
statute uh since they're concerned
that uh
they that this the statute does not may
not give them that Authority why not
give them why not we give them that
Authority immediately
as or immediately as possible uh in a in
the the specific Dees statute the 484 uh
482a
uh I don't think that I have much else
to say on that I think other than
that uh we should do these things this
as quickly I feel they should do this as
quickly as possible to have
that their ability to regulate the the
uh The Cutting of native
vegetation in uh in the our
Lakes should not go be lost we it's
there's a clear and present danger I
think on that in that respect so
uh
that's that's all I have to say I think
you might wish to listen to folks uh
behind me and they tell you about uh the
specific
uh Lake that has has has an issue around
this
uh The Cutting of the the vegetation and
uh you know and I'll just yield the
floor thank you representative any
questions for representative
Rula representative
run thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm just curious why um invasive species
weren't included in this amendment well
invasive species are already already
included in a another section of the law
yeah any other questions for the
representative representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question um the the bill that you're
amending is is a you know well supported
bill um I I believe that the we heard
that department of environmental service
is you know thinks this is an important
bill sometimes um non- gerine amendments
can act as poison pills when they get on
the other side of the wall are you you
have any concerns about
that not in
well not in this not in this case I
think this uh I I uh I think that the uh
it can be a a poison pill this is not a
poison pill believe me this is uh this
is something something that uh uh that I
really will think is important from a
point of view of uh leaving the V
leaving we leaving the Lakes the lakes
are vulnerable now in this in this
instance if uh people who
are uh people the people who are who are
there
to to protect the lakes and they're the
experts if they're not if if they're not
at least monitoring what's
happening uh we we are the the likees
the Lakes will be in
danger any other followup thank you Mr
chair thank thank you
again um so I I I very much appreciate
this bill and I spent a lot of time
reading uh researching based on your
amendment I can't find in um section 487
RSA 487
where it talks about um cut cutting
aquatic vegetation it does talk a lot
about studies it talks about um grants
to control them but it doesn't
specifically talk about cutting so then
I went to the um the dees rules and I
couldn't find any rules either about um
cutting aquatic vegetation and we know
um I know because I've you know as a as
a lak fromont property owner that
cutting mil foil is about the worst
thing you can do because it spreads it
and so I'm very concerned that if we
don't also allow rule making around
cutting all vegetation native and
invasive then we're leaving a whole do
you have any comments on that rule
making does exist uh I've handed out a
uh uh a packet and in there is the
chapter least and I pled this out by the
way yeah
yesterday so it's no uh no I didn't send
it out no I didn't send it out I printed
it so it's uh if you look at the chapter
uh
in uh it's uh chapter EnV
wt500 and you'll see in the very be very
beginning on the first page you'll see a
line just go go through that's okay
you'll see a line there where it says
uh this there's mentions the including
aquatic vegetation control water access
structure you know it's appr Pro is
let's
see discusses project criteria approval
under RSA
482a might be needed including aquatic
vegetation control that's on page one
uh on I'm just finding areas where they
talk
about Native
vegitation uh and we go to on page
three uh where it's talk
about uh part EnV WT 510 aquatic
vegetation control it says this part uh
part shall apply to projects for removal
of an aqua of a native aquatic
vegetation nav and exotic ex aquatic
weeds ew e
a
uh they go to you got it now
okay and anyone well what am I
doing I know I can pass this down no
please please um any other questions for
representative
rulu seeing none thank you
representative speaking in favor of the
non- gerain amendment Julia
marome mansome
mome would you spell your last name
Julia for the record
indeed it's mosson m a WS o n thank you
um I Mr chairman I'm pleased to be here
I was wondering would it be possible for
Mrs Kamal to uh sit with me and actually
speak
first she has a card yes you can do that
thank
you this is Christine Kamal also uh from
palum speaking in
support I love working with pristine but
I must admit that at times
I SAR and of them
else thank you Mr chairperson and
members of the committee I appreciate
this opportunity to speak uh my name is
Christine Kamal I own a home on uh 59
Southshore Drive in pelum New Hampshire
on Little Island Pond I also served on
our local Conservation
Commission um I'm in favor of this bill
uh to um uh 15 um excuse me
1554 with amendment to permit um or give
authority to the Department of
Environmental Services to regulate The
Cutting of native aquatic
vegetation um and the reason being is
native aquatic vegetation plays a vital
role in our Lake ecology it actually
helps to keep the water clear and it
also uh keeps um a healthy aquatic
ecosystem uh we've got nutrients coming
into our lakes and ponds uh these um The
Aquatic vegetation and CYO bacteria need
these nutrients to grow and proliferate
when you cut native aquatic vegetation
that and you remove it from the water
water
body the cob bacteria gets all the
nutrients there's no
competition and with that said I'd like
to share with you a very compelling
story uh what happens when unregulated
cutting is allowed to happen on our
lakes in 2022 Our Lake Association
decided to cut the Troublesome uh uh
weeds um they started cutting native
aquatic vegetation with hand rakes
despite uh several experts who advise
them not to take a heavy-handed
approach um a conservative estimate was
1.2 million square
feet was cut and removed from the lake
and uh the statutes um that um uh
rep um Rula was referring to uh a major
project is considered one greater than
10,000 square feet so uh 1.2 million
square feet of native aquatic
V uh the next year 2023 uh last summer
they purchased what's called a Water
Gator and in that packet I provided
images uh the last page shows the Water
Gator it's the size of like a little
Fiat um it has uh it's Opera remote
control there's a chaser boat that
follows it uh it has blades that are
adjustable they said that this machine
could cut in a half hour what it took
three days to do with handres and if you
look very carefully you can see that um
one of the downsides is that this uh
aquatic machine fails to pick up all the
cut vegetation you can see it in the
image floating all
around um these cuting can also
reestablish themselves by Falling to the
bottom not just by seed uh case in point
to drive home how much vegetation was
being cut one day a few friends went out
and uh we just taken a leisurely paddle
board and it was the day following the
Harvester when it had gone out uh we got
to the west side of the lake and uh it
was filled with floating cut vegetation
everywhere uh we knew this wasn't good
so we proceeded to pick it up with our
hands and pile it up on our boards and
uh there was three of us out there and
within less than two hours we had must
have picked up a dozen piles like the
size you see on those boards that was
not from boat activity that was left
over from that aquatic Harvester and let
me remind you you don't need a permit
you don't need a license you don't have
to be a limnologist or a biologist you
don't even have to have knowledge of an
aquatic ecosystem to operate one of
these things and uh so with that said
bring us to August 2023 Last Summer sum
we had an unprecedented 71 days with CYO
bacteria advisories starting in August
we started seeing cob bacteria blooms
and they continued till um November 8th
was the last day and in one of the
photos there you're going to see this
image of this bright green Soo Bloom
that was posted on our Lake Facebook
page comment started coming in oh my
gosh I've never seen anything like this
in all my years living on the pond oh my
gosh what's causing this um there was a
lot of concern raised
uh and then lastly and I would like to
mention that the Department of
Environmental Services recognizes the
value of native aquatic vegetation uh
I've also included that in the letter
that's in your
packet um uh they have an article a fact
sheet titled aquatic plants and their
role in Lake ecology and in there they
say however complete removal of native
aquatic plants is not recommended not
only is it costly and practical and may
need a permit it is detri mental to a
lake healthy
ecosystem um and then they go on to say
that this has been proven in a number of
New Hampshire Lakes where where
disturbances in Native aquatic
vegetation has occurred um in conclusion
I I I implore and I ask that you please
uh vote Yes on um this bill I thank you
for your time and I'll turn it over to
Julia before Julia speaks any questions
for Miss Kamal
representative Iran thank you Mr chair
and thank you Miss komal for taking my
question the last photo you have is that
a picture of the machine yes oh okay and
so what's on top of it has already been
cut so yes it's a so there's a conveyor
belt and as the machine's cutting the
vegetation is supposed to go up on that
conveyor belt but as you can see and
from our experience it's not effective
at collecting the cut vegetation it just
you have wave action you have wind
action and that can cause the vegetation
to drift way off okay thank you any
other questions from Miss
Cal seeing none will turn to Julia
Julia Shoot actually I can take you
can
thank you so
much appreciate it you're a good
partner
good morning everyone my name is Julia
Steed mosson I live on 17 Southshore
Drive in palum New Hampshire on Little
Island Pond uh I'm a biologist and
environmental educator I'm also uh an
extension educator ameritus with UNH
Cooperative Extension and I'm delighted
to be here with you today um to follow
on Christine's uh comments um one of the
things as a biologist that I know is
incredibly important is that when
natural systems and humans interact we
sometimes need to engage management
whether it's forests or fields or in our
case aquatic systems like Lakes um I do
support House Bill 1554 as amended uh
this bill is incredibly important
because while there is language in our
New Hampshire law regarding
um vegetation management the emphasis
appears to be more on the issue of
invasives and yes natives are mentioned
but at the same time there's a there's a
lack of clarity about how how the laws
can actually be applied um law is not my
wheelhouse but I've been trying to read
very very carefully what is available
and thanks to Christine and her Eagle
Eye on being able to read little tiny
type I'm trying to learn more and
understand it more but what I can see is
it really appears to lead to some
confusion because of this lack of
clarity concerning the actual Authority
that Dees has regarding the management
of native aquatic
vegetation now because Lake systems are
very complex there's a lot of moving
Parts um management of these systems
needs to be done extremely carefully and
that means that need to have uh
Community engagement you need to have
good planning you need to have good
oversight you need to have good
evaluation afterwards um we also know as
Christine said that our native aquatic
vegetation is extremely important
because of the ecological functions that
they can perform and loss of Native
aquatic vegetation is extremely bad for
our ecological
systems so they need protection and they
sometimes need
management now um we have had four
agencies Dees New Hampshire Lakes UNH
Cooperative Extension uh with the lakes
l monitoring program and also uh the
private consultant for aquatic uh
ecosystem research and all of them have
cautioned us and she mentioned that
phrase heavy-handed she caution they
cautioned us against a heavy-handed
approach to actually any aqu itic
vegetation management but in particular
when we're thinking about natives
because when that happens there really
four four major kinds of things that can
happen one is that you can inadvertently
be spreading the vegetation that you're
trying to control because fragments
break off seeds gets dispersed they can
also cause a problem where uh when when
vegetation is removed nutrients can be
that nutrient balance can be changed and
therefore or that can also lead to uh
the situation where there's more
proclivity for invasives to be able to
establish themselves because you you've
changed that balance of competition the
other thing that's important in
management is being very careful that uh
that also you're not uh again that
change of um the balance of nutrients
you're not making it a fow ground for
more
cyanobacteria and then the last thing is
that all of this again this is all
complicated they're all inter we we all
interdependent and so therefore water
quality can be changed as
well so um I have looked at several uh
long-term management plans uh that we
have in New Hampshire there's there's
one right here it's Flint Pond from
Hollis and they're managing for mil foil
I did not give you copies of it it's 48
pages long because it's
comprehensive doing all those things
that I mentioned before that are
important with good management
planning I've looked at several other
management plans and of course Dees has
had to help with this thank heavens for
Dees so all of these plans are they're
they don't follow the exact same boiler
plate because every lake is different
every Community around them it's not
just when you're doing these plans it's
not just the lake itself but it's also
the the human Community as well where
are the L where are the the wells
located what are the transportation
issues what are the roads all those
things that come into play with these
plans so this is very comprehensive it's
48 pages some of them are 30 some of
them are 60 now I want to show you what
we have for the plan for little Island
Pond what we have is this we have two
paragraphs now I want to be very clear
that I support Dees is this wrong no it
is not wrong is it not the best
absolutely it's not the best because
whether it's invasive or whether it's
native and if their needs to be
management and that's part of the
component is is there a need that the
whether it's native or invasive and if
it has to be managed it has to be done
carefully so a two-page
paragraph doesn't appear to me to be
adequate however we have to remember
that Dees must with work within the
guidelines of the legislation and so
therefore they must be extremely careful
when they're actually working with
communities in order to enact these
sorts of things that we're talking about
so having said all
that lack of O oversight you might say
well what's the big deal there is a big
deal because all of these aquatic
systems are
interconnected so if there's
mismanagement in a lake like little
Island Pond that's going to result in
say more cyano bacteria we actually saw
71 days of cyano this year who knows
what you have to watch this over time as
well but whatever happens in Little
Island Pond it can flow down into the
wetlands it can impact also people that
have their Wells it can flow into
groundwater and the and the aquifer
itself so it's all interconnected so
mismanagement in a lake can have great
implications for the lands around it as
well so for this
reason I want to say that I I again I
fully support de's work their work is
hard they do great work they're working
in complex systems with the complexities
of us the general public but we want to
make sure that we have the right
language to give them the tools that
they need to do the work they do so that
they can help us and we can work
together to make sure that these shared
resources that we have in our lakes in
our ponds in our wetlands are protected
and well used and well-managed this is
not a one Lake issue we know know that
we have our waters are warming we know
that nutrient loading is happening in
our Lakes throughout the state these
things um the nutrient loading issue is
also secondary to the incremental
impacts of development and let's face it
after covid everybody wanted to go live
on their Lake and be away from everyone
else but still have a great time but
these complexities are really causing a
lot of pressure on our New Hampshire
lakes and quite frankly on our staff at
Dees so therefore we need to work and
we're asking you to support this
legislation excuse me to make sure that
Dees has the tools it needs to do so
that all of our Lakes are protected down
the line and again issues of warming
issues of nutrient loading in issues of
the incremental impacts of development
those three things are not going to go
away this is our future that we need to
think about and we need to prepare
ourselves and help Dees to be able to do
the work now but also down the line
having said all that I thank you very
much I appreciate all of your time I
know that you're very busy please
support this important legislation
brought forth by representative rulu and
we thank him for that as well thank you
any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you both for
your testimony thank you kindly next
speaker Andrea Laro New Hampshire
Lakes good morning chair and members of
the committee I'm Andrea lamro president
of New Hampshire lakes and I'm here to
speak in support of HB 1554 as amended
uh representative Rulo Christine and
Julia did a terrific job explaining all
the reasons why we support this bill so
I just want to reiterate that this is a
Statewide problem and going forward
having a proper oversight of these type
of projects will help to avoid unended
consequences of uh impacts to our water
quality and as a result impacts to our
ability to recreate impacts to property
values and down the line so um again I
urge you to support this bill as amended
and I'm happy to answer any questions
any question representative R thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh you mentioned this is a
Statewide problem do you have specific
examples as was the experience at Little
Island Pond in pelum where there was a
widespread cutting of um aquatic
vegetation that may or may not have led
to problems great question I don't have
a specific example now um I did speak
with Amy smug at the Department of
Environmental Services and she has
indicated in the past there have been uh
projects in which um rais some biolog
some concerns um as you know she's a
biologist with the Department um I'm
happy to reach out to see if if there
are any specific um examples that she's
able to share but at this time I'm not
aware of any other specific
thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you is there anyone else that wishes to
speak I don't have any more pink cards
on HB 1554 the non gerain
Amendment seeing no one approaching the
mic I'll close the hearing on HB
1554 thank
you
we were scheduled at 10:30 to exec a
number of bills because of the last two
hearings going longer than anticipated
we'll take a short four or five minute
break and then we'll come back and
immediately uh in the order that you see
them listed we'll uh start to EXA those
bills thank
you
e
I'll go oh yes much ask chair recognizes
representative
Veil thank you Mr chairman um I just
wanted to Welcome to our executive
session representative Dennis Malloy
he's from Ways and Means and uh we
really appreciate you pitching in to
help with us today your name turns up in
a a lot of this
legislation and it's
appreciated first on the
agenda
is House Bill 15 13 relative to board of
directors of the PE Development
Authority do I hear a
motion representative representative
lontine for a motion I'd like to make to
make a motion of
itl on 1513 is there a second on the
motion second by representative rung
would you like to speak on your
motion yes I I don't see any need to
changed the way the board is appointed
now I think the bill proposes to take
away um important local
control and already the the governor and
the executive Council um appoint four of
the members of the
board and um I think that is
enough and uh the PDA seems to be
working very well and the chair of the
board definitely wanted to see the this
bill um it so i' would like to support
that and think it's pretty
straightforward would you like to speak
to your
second thank you Mr chair I I just want
to um mention representative har brought
up a good point um during the public
hearing that there may be a
non-legislative remedy of uh by
addressing this through the bylaws so I
definitely support the itl thank you
there anyone else wishes represent
representative
Veil thank you Mr chairman um I believe
that this bill would have profound
economic impact on the area surrounding
um the P's former Air Force Base and I
think that when you're looking at
cumulative impacts on the environment
you are looking to the people that are
living with these impacts which are the
abutters to the area and to me it is an
incredible project um we heard in the
testimony that it was Forward Thinking
30 years ago to look at what is the
responsibility of the Air Force and what
is responsibility of the state and other
federal agencies um in the transition to
private property so for me this would be
a regression that we don't want to take
a chance on right now so I just strongly
urge the sponsors if they're looking
to um to take the advice that came up
during the hearing um and come back with
a better Bill if needed thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on the uh on the motion if not
will the clerk please call the
rooll thank you very much um on House
Bill 1513 motion of IDL representative
harb yes representative gouls yes
representative Horgan yes CL votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes representative run yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
F
yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Malloy yes and the
chair yes that is 20 to zero motion
passes consent calendar any on the
consent
calendar and we'll move move on to House
Bill
1554 relative to certified Culvert
maintenance program
reporting let me turn this over the
gavel over to representative harb and
he'll thank you on thank you on 1554 do
I have a motion of a to
pass representative vulo I move on to
pass way have a
second seconded by representative
Kelly you have a
motion motion to
amend
Amendment uh adopt
Amendment uh
0969 H 2024 right
2024 we have a second on the
amendment representative Vale seconds
the
amendment representative Ru Rula would
you like to speak on your motion to
amend well we just had a
fairly extensive uh meeting a few
minutes ago uh on this bill I don't
think I want to go in on this amendment
they all you all heard it and I'll I
think uh we'll just move on
does the second wish to
speak I agree um thank you Mr chair that
we have heard what we need to know I
think thus far thank you anyone else
wish to speak on the
amendment seeing none uh clerk can call
the role on the
amendment thank you on the
amendment
uh representative harb yes
representative G yes
representative organ yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vil yes representative run yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoy yes representative L montine yes
representative lit yes representative
Malloy yes and the chair yes Amendment
passes now on the ought to pass as
amended anyone wish to speak on
that seeing none can the cler did you
want to speak I almost also wish
on uh we now we're at to pass as amended
uh we there also is part of this bill
concerns the uh uh the certification of
uh culbert maintenance programming that
is also part of the bill that I uh that
that is uh that is that is a good bill
and I think the the what's been
requested by by the department is uh is
appropriate so I I uh
I I would uh recomend men
passage anyone yes representative
Vale Mr chair thank you Mr chair as
amended this bill contains something
really important that we need to be
doing and I'm glad that the committee
has some agreement in regards to trying
to help stem the flow of um cyano
bacteria and the effect that um cutting
in such a irres responsible way is um
affecting particular lakes and putting
them out of business for 71 days a year
is as compelling evidence so thank you
for bringing forward the amendment and
also on the regular on the bill itself
that was requested by Dees and I think
it's a good change that will be helpful
to
them thank you anyone else to
speak seeing none can the clerk call the
role on the ought to pass as has amended
HB
1554 yes thank you very much
representative herb yes representative
GS yes representative organ yes CL votes
yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
MCU yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin
yes representative Derby yes
representative hoit yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Malloy yes the chair yes
20 to zero those
passes
consent y consent
okay turn the chair back to
representative ranula thank you now we
have a house bill
1113 Shoreland septic
system uh
there uh I I I'm going to step out I
there's a issue with this uh with the
amendment of this bill is this was this
that's what I've uh in conversation few
minutes ago with
the rep the miss the representative of
De from Dees so I will I'd like to
recognize him to speak to the issues
that what he wants to what he what his
concern is before we
uh before we proceed if uh I use usually
don't usually I I I'm really looking for
is a clarification so uh I'm allowed to
I think I'm allowed to do that uh to uh
get a clarification on certain
things before we proceed thank you
chairman rillo for the record my name is
Philip trobridge from the Department of
Environmental Services um speaking
regarding House Bill
1113 um the
um the there's been an attempt to make
an amendment to this bill we've worked
with representative harb on that um and
that Amendment we think would benefit
from a little extra time to discuss with
other parties um a lot of the work was
done uh with the Realtors
association and um having some
discussions today with representatives
from the designers and installers and
evaluators groups uh they would like a
little more time to discuss it so if
there is an opportunity for that um we
would welcome
that the
as as I as I uh as I have explained that
we are up against a a
deadline if uh we put
the uh the LA the last day we could
actually have a hearing would be if it
be next
Wednesday it would be the one day before
the deadline and that's cutting it well
very close
we it also would require us to come back
again for that
day uh I put going to put it to the
committee they want to to do this uh the
uh there is also you know
a uh possibility
that uh you know we could we could
actually correct any issue with a floor
Amendment if um if the if we do pass the
bill so I'm going to put this to the
committee I see representative Wolf's
hand first but then uh representative
wolf then repres representative
Darby thank you Mr chair um as you know
I spoke with you earlier today about uh
extending one week on um House Bill
390 I didn't realize there was anybody
else that was was looking for an
extension neither did
I well I didn't pull out out of that um
anyway um now there are two possible
bills to that are being asked to
postpone um I think in the point of
getting our legislation right and
accurate and inconveniencing ourselves a
little bit I would suggest that we do
delay this for one week and hopefully
you'll give me the same courtesy when I
come forward on my
bill anyone else wish to speak on
the
yes thank you um how uh is it something
that you can work on and and fix in the
week and then we can back and do it on
Wednesday yes I believe so I think a
number of key people have been out of
town and there's just some discussions
that need to be had okay great thank you
appreciate
it follow up or follow up um in which
case I'm good waiting a week um I will
put it first I need to hear
everyone do you have want to say
something to
representative yes uh as Mr Trowbridge
mentioned uh I had a discussion with the
department and on Monday I talked to Mr
deer I'm just surprised by the request
because it wasn't mentioned to me on
Monday I just want the record to know
that I wouldn't have put the amendment
forward if I had been told that perhaps
on Monday but I appreciate the request
thank you Senator
Bale I think um thank you Mr
chair what we should probably do is just
see I mean I I think that this could be
amended on the floor to include things
um that were not thought of um prior to
the filing of this amendment and that
would give us um we would still have the
time um my understanding is the work we
do on this bill will you know it it
wouldn't be something that we would be
debating if we were to put the time into
putting in a floor Amendment on the
other hand we do have next week there
may be other matters that we need to um
postpone until next week so I leave it
to everyone involved to decide what to
do I just want to further my support for
um uh coming back next week um for these
two important bills that are not quite
ready uh to EXA today in my opinion
thank
you representative
Rong yeah um I've worked on this bill
for months and I've had discussions with
both the realtors association and Dees I
am curious to see what's missing from
the this amendment but I am willing to
support putting it off until next week
particularly since there's likely going
to be another bill that we'd have to
delay um and and I I just have
tremendous appreciation to
representative har for picking up on
this amendment and following through
with it uh as I was dealing with my
family emergency this week thank you
okay
it's as chair I have the authority to
call any meeting anytime I want but this
in this
instance
uh I'll let the the I'll let the body
decide whether they wish to uh spend
another another uh day that you would
have had off next week to in here uh
I'll I I will not do this as I will as a
overall uh well a push off of of any
bill that we don't that we're not
certain of or don't like this is this we
we'll do this on on each individual
bill now so if if because I've been I've
been told that there are some bills that
might that there are amendments that
were asked for and uh may not have may
not be here that may
require also the
our are being here another day but uh if
we if a bill is ready to
go uh I I I will not uh and somebody
just wants to move it off again that's
going to take another vote of this
committee so
uh representative representative
mck thank you Mr chairman Mr Trish can
you just give us a an idea what it is
you may want to further
modify
um just an idea of the complexity is it
something that we could easily change on
the floor just to save 20 people in in
staff and these folks from coming back
next week for one bill um it I guess the
the the thing that we'd like to be doing
and we weren't aware of potential
concerns that were held by the designers
and installers side of this you know
part of this process and so we need to
have those conversations to make sure
that they support it uh so I don't know
if they will have any opposition or not
it may be nothing but it's a
conversation that we I think would be
good for good to be have had before
going to um voting it on the house
floor so so could be no change at
all and they
could have of course could have input
with their representatives before we
vote on in the house and then again in
the Senate so we could come back next
week for absolutely no changes no
amendments no nothing that's possible
yes okay
thanks then Mr chairman I'd say given
that we don't even know there's an
amendment
I mean I'm I'm happy to go with the will
of the committee but if we don't even
know what it's that there is an
amendment I understand is it worth it
what does the committee think I don't
know I've given well you've I put it on
the floor to the committee I'm not going
to pull it back
uh where what is the uh show a hands how
many people will be willing to uh want
would would be willing to come in on
next next week to have a uh to have a
hearing uh to complete the
hearing on uh on this
bill looks like
a don't know if look like a
majority all right all right oh you
can't can't
all right of the 19 people all right
raise your hands again and better yet
please call the
all can we just count or just I can't
count I'm to TI Go I you're a clerk you
do the count
everybody is this to what to come back
next
week eight out of
Mone you don't have
it okay so we proceed then with
the proceed with the bill and if there
is a an issue uh we can we'll bring it
forth on the
uh on the
next thank you for your
consideration yeah go thank you although
the board voted to um or the committee
voted to take this up today I am sure
representative rang and I would be happy
to talk to Dees and if it's a reasonable
request for a floor Amendment we may be
able to work it out and do a joint floor
Amendment just so you'll
know he you ought to be chair
here I was taught well represent
all
right on house okay how House Bill
11 1113
[Music]
111313 recognize representative
rung I move a to
pass I'll second
that you have a mo you have a uh motion
of a to passes open to amendment I have
an amendment Mr chair you I'd like to
propose uh Amendment
224-1
77h believe everyone has a copy at their
place and I also emailed one out
earlier second by represent
representative rung is there any
discussion on the like to
discuss I have a small discussion um on
my Amendment uh and I'd like to thank
representative rung for beginning this
amendment and getting it uh put
to uh writing I had an opportunity on
Monday to review uh the proposed
amendment with Mr dear and Ted dear and
also with the uh chairman of the New
Hampshire board of realtors I believe
it's Bob Dunn uh I made one slight
Amendment at the time to representative
rang's amendment that she supports which
was to change the time that um the
septic system would need to be reped
from 6 months to one year and although I
always catch flak and comments on it uh
some of you know my major practice in
real estate is in Massachusetts and I
was there before the startat of Title 5
that's how long I've been there and uh
Title 5 enables the um repair to be
within a year year and it's been in Mass
for quite a while and that seems to work
with the Realtors the bar and everyone
else so I just simply suggested that I
would make that change I did advise Mr
deer that I would be making that change
and the board of realtor supported it
and told me that's was what they were
hoping they could get so other than that
I I representative rang and I worked on
this and I think it's a good amendment I
think we're all in favor of protecting
the Lakes and our water supplies and as
uh Mr de reminded me this is on
waterfront property and uh for some of
you that may not be aware the amendment
uh changed the 200 ft to 250 because the
shorland protection act is 250 I was
reminded of that so I think this
amendment makes sense I think it goes a
long way would it need amendments in the
future I know some of you have suggested
maybe some I'd say yeah but I'd like to
see see this get into effect so that we
can work immediately to protect our
water system thank
you would you like to speak to your
second yes thank you very much Mr chair
um I also want to bring attention to um
section six which addresses a lot of the
concerns that were raised at the public
hearing regarding people buying property
to raise it and then build another
property it would need a new septic
system design that the original build
didn't account for that um like why
would we expect a seller to have a
operational septic system if that's just
going to be removed so that takes into
account a lot of those issues I I that
came up um and again um I I really
appreciate um representative har you
know polishing the the St the stone on
this one uh it really helps and it is a
very good
Amendment this committee has for at
least the six years I've been on it been
addressing Shoreline septic system
issues we've heard in committee um at
the hearing about the contribution they
have to the phosphorus that contributes
to cyano bacteria blooms it could be
anywhere from 11 to 20% and um this is a
good first step to getting a handle on
controlling phosphorus coming from fail
septic systems that exist on the
shoreline so thank
you
representative Darby for a comment thank
you Mr chair so this I do definitely uh
support the amendment I just wanted to
point out a few um uh points that I made
to representative harb privately um
which is the reason I am was encouraging
um delaying a week so that these could
be
incorporated I'll do them last to first
because the first is the most
controversial but um as an example the
um the disclosures the New Hampshire the
realtor disclosures um contain language
about um about the existing statute for
um what is it
um about the the evaluation the the
waste the septic evaluation so those
forms have to change and typically um
when the forms have to change the
Realtors are asked to make those changes
on the first of the year and so the
effective date I think should be moved
to the first year rather than 60 days
secondly there's a few places where um
the it says that the evaluator these are
in um you know Sub sub paragraphs five
um sub paragraphs A and B where it says
that the evaluators um need to provide
uh information or need to notify about
the um about the failed system but
there's some cases where it's actually
the designer that detects it instead of
the evaluator and so the language should
be change to say the evaluator or
designer a third case is that
um
uh um so the bill says that the seller
the buyer can perform the um septic um
evaluation um on um and on behalf of the
buyer so that basically if if you think
your if you think your system's in
Failure you want to figure it out ahead
of time um it doesn't have that same
caveat for um if you have an old system
that requires the septic syst septic
system designer to come back so I think
that caveat should be added because
right now the burden is always on the
buyer um and and those issues might not
be determined until late in the game
which might actually cause problems with
the transaction and then most
importantly although something I'm
willing to overlook for um for this bill
um for because the amendment is so
important is that the penalty um right
now of $500 if you don't comply with the
um the Waterfront evaluation has been
removed
so potentially there's other ways that
the this can be enforced but um the very
explicit $500 penalty has been removed
and um I think that's a consideration as
well so I'll be supporting the amendment
Unless somehow I can get people to um
push this out a week but um I just
wanted to um point out my um my concerns
in case there is an amendment that maybe
these could be rolled in for the floor
Amendment thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
amendment seeing no one will the clerk
please call a rooll on the
amendment on the amendment for House
Bill 113 representative harb yes
representative gold yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn
yes representative Vale
yes uh representative BR yes
representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin
yes representative Derby yes
representative poit yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative
Malloy yes and the chair yes 20 to zero
motion
passes that's on the amendment Amendment
okay on a motion that ought to pass as
amended is any wish to
speak no one wishes to speak then I'm
the to pass as
amended and court please call the role
yes the motion is uh ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
113 well uh actually this you I don't
think you have to because I think you
you made them original out to pass
motion oh no wait a minute you did not
think but there was an original art to
pass motion M yeah right if we need a
new motion Mr chair I'm happy to to pass
his amendment I know it's done both ways
yeah Mr chair I think our customs been
that we have an ought to pass motion
then there's an amendment accepted and
then there's a roll call on the
amendment then there's a roll call on
the
otpa because it because it's now just
been amended right the qu question was
do you have a new should you have a new
a to pass as amended motion and and I've
seen it done both ways and I think I've
done it both ways so uh on the clerk
will the clerk please call the role yes
representative harb yes representative
GS yes representative Horgan yes clerk
votes yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
MCU yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes yes representative Baldwin
yes representative Derby yes
representative hoit yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Malloy yes and the clerk
uh chair yes that's 20 to zero motion
passes yeah oh now I if there's in the
this probably should not go on consent
simply because we if we do have a floor
amendment that we want to put on it
would save us having to find 10 people
and so and get it off the and also any
time you get a something off of consent
it's at the end of the calendar and all
kinds of strange things happen so I was
go I would suggest we keep it on the uh
on the regular calendar
and Ina in case of that need need uh
okay that closes House Bill
1113 now go to House Bill
is 721 relatives are creating certain
Wetland permit exemptions after a
natural disaster or flooding
event cler
motion for for a motion uh uh thank you
Mr chair I'd like to make a motion of a
to pass and I have an
amendment um on House Bill
1121 Mr the chair I'll second the Au to
pass
okay and uh proposing you're proposing
an amendment yes um um
okay I wrote it down okay it's uh
amendment number
112h and should all have a copy of that
um M Forest um from Wetland was very
gracious in working with us um on this
language and um we think we have it in
the right section of
Statute um it uh cleans up a lot of what
um representative Aaron had originally
and simplifies it quite a bit I realized
that uh um Miss force is working on the
rules um and she'll be coming forth with
some rules that are going to uh expound
upon this and we appreciate that very
much um this uh Amendment just simply
clarifies um the same thing it allows uh
removal of Woody
debris in in uh water courses and
channels so I appreciate it very much um
I think it's pretty straightforward
so thank
you anyone else you wish to speak on the
uh on your on your
second no I have nothing further to say
Mr chair thank you anyone wish to speak
uh for or against the mo the uh
Amendment seeing seeing none on the
amendment will clerk please call the
rooll yes thank you on the amendment for
112 one representative harp yes
representative gold yes representative
Horgan yes cler votes yes representative
Healey yes representative
wolf representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Veil
yes represent restive R
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Balman yes representative
Darby yes representative hoit yes
representative lontine yes
representative lit yes represent Malloy
yes and the chair yes it's 20 to zero
Mar
passes that's on the amendment that's on
the am on the amendment yeah on ought to
pass as amend motion now ought to pass
as
amended is there wish to speak on the
motion about the pass as
amended uh nope I said it all I guess I
should have been speaking to the
original Bill a little bit more but I
already spoke so okay I think you've got
it thank you thank
you representative
harp no I just support report uh this
bill as amended for the reasons stated
by uh representative harby boy okay
thank you I have to pass as amended on a
motion of about the pass representative
R thank you Mr chair um I know that um
during the public hearing there was some
concern by Dees and I since Miss Forest
this year I was wondering if she could
just give her um how how she sees this
amendment um being able to um provide
her support to the bill the underlying
bill is that possible
uh it's want would have been better
before we took the vote on
Amendment I'll I'll allow it thank you
Mr chair you wish to just say how you
feel about the
amendment or or what bill has
amended have any
OB
okay that answer your question I
know representa you're not pointing that
way you
want
okay that one D you do didn't swear at
me in sign
[Laughter]
language
um thankk you Mr chair uh I do have
concerns about this bill I don't think
we need the bill and I do know that
there is Ru making we are going through
um a time when there's an app and a
process being developed to quickly be
able to report these kinds of events um
but you know I strongly heard and I
guess I would want to hear more that
um we would
not be giving any additional power to
people than they already have in statute
to be able to mitigate the damage that
comes from these
events that's what I remember from the
testimony so at um today I'll be voting
against the autop pass is amended and I
look forward to the rule making to take
place and for us to be able to see what
those processes will be and see how we
can help with that when it comes along
if we need to address it in statute
thank you
anyone
else really quickly um thank you for
your comments representative veale I
just wanted to mention that um we took
the language out of all already that was
already sort of in rules about um that
they can only remove Woody debris uh
provided that sediment disturbance is
minimized and no in the results in no
new permanent impacts and that was to
keep it in context with um the most
important element of removal of Woody de
bre which is not to create any new
impacts uh to their neighbors
neighboring uh Parcels thank
you anyone else representative
Derby thank you Mr chair I I do have a
question that I I appreciate very much
the work that uh representative Harvey
willia put into this but I do have a
question about what permanent impacts
means that I was wondering if I could
ask a specific question to M Forest
about I say
uh forc where you uh but on behalf of
the dees heard you well I ask Dees and
Miss Force forced as a representative of
Dees and the the representative of Dees
that um that testified on this bill uh
to begin with that's why I would like to
ask her for this clarification will you
will you
yield the room to answer questions okay
then you heard the question can you
comment on we we heard several scenarios
that were discussed um uh during
testimony one of those was where you
know new um new large rocks Boulders
block the the main Channel and basically
divert the channel would you consider
the removal of Boulders from the main
Channel this is a clarification yes yes
yes yeah but don't don't you so far I
haven't heard of you're just about to I
mean like literally one word away yeah
this isn't like a regular hearing I know
I know but I'm just trying to understand
um if the removing of large rocks from
the middle of the Channel which is what
this says from the um from the channel
would be considered a permanent um a a
permanent what is the word here um
permanent
impact thank you thank
you any anyone
else representing M since we're
apparently taking testimony how big do
the rocks have to
be see
darling Force Department of
Environmental Services Wetland Bureau uh
the question was asked what would the
department consider to be a permanent
impact the permanent impact is one where
you are by rule already defined it's one
where you
are moving sediment you are moving fill
or you are constructing a structure with
no intent of undoing that change so if
you remove material that is or that is
mineral material that we regulate
normally requiring a permit with no
intention to
restore that would meet our existing
definition of permanent impact so this
should not get into intentional removal
of normal River
substrates sorry representive Derby
asked you about rocks and big rocks and
I'm just wondering how big do the rocks
have to be before you consider it a a
permanent
modification like how how do you make
that judgment I really don't know so I'm
generally asking so and and that's not
an easy question to answer because it
would have to be something that we would
have to be able to quantify it would
have to be measurable observable
documentable so we recognize that
anytime someone goes in and they're
moving Woody debris as you pick it up
there's likely to be some fines that
will mobilize that there's no reasonable
way to document
and um document that
and measure
that we won't
be it's not practical pursue that and
it's also impossible to to do the work
that we've telling people they could do
without that happening but if in fact
you went in with equipment and began to
move um or mineral material around in a
way that you could photo document a
change in
Contour
um either deposition or fill whether
you're adding or taking
away and you could measure
it that would be
the that would be the threshold before
we would take an action I I wish I could
offer you something more but it has to
be a documentable measurable thing
otherwise there's no evidence that
anything happened that we could enforce
on no no more questions for instance
like if if there were a navigation ha
third no more qu no Oh I thought you
said further question sorry Mr chair no
not further question sorry further wait
I misheard you I thought you said
further question you it's got obviously
G to have to take my
medicine
thank you very
much I'm seeing no more no
more questions wish think
this don't don't ask her it's not for
this is a comment only to the other
Representatives I'm not going to
entertain any more
clarifications representative L
montin um I appreciate the um that the
amendment is is much simpler and that
you've included um you know that
sediment distur disturbance is minimized
and the work results and no permanent
impacts um but I I feel
it initially I felt that we didn't
necessarily have a problem that that
Dees already had
procedures to deal with um cleanup after
um an
event um and that people already
could withdraw um Woody debris from
streams
um but and I worry a little bit that
we're opening this up to damage being
called and then Dees comes in have to
come in later and say document that the
disturbance happened as a result of the
cleanup which was not
permitted um you know when a after the
hearing
earlier I heard um someone in favor of
the bill saying I don't know why we just
can't bring our bulldozer in the Stream
and clean it up so that's what I'd sort
of like to avoid
happening um and that I feel like the
language um still leaves it pretty wide
open as to how um the cleanup would take
place so and for that reason I oppose
the
bill
as a
minut okay anyone
else seeing no one else on the ought to
pass as amended clerk please call the
role yes thank you Mr chair as amended
on House Bill 1121 representative harb
yes representative GS yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes
reluctantly representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale no representative rug
yes okay representative Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative hoit
yes Representative lontine
no representative lit
yes representative Malloy
no okay and the
chair yes right okay that's 17-3 motion
passes 17-3 I guess that's regular
calendar if will there be a
Minority Report or you can get your will
L montain for Minority
Report actually if there is a Minority
Report it cannot yeah it's got to be
regular
calar Y
and represent Harvey bolia for uh
majority was the
majority
okay all
right closes uh
11:21 uh House Bill
1301 relative to
Wick yeah relative to wake surfing on
public bodies of
water representative Harvey Julia do you
have recognized for a motion yes um
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion of itl on House Bill
1301 is there a
second have a second who's the
second second by representative wolf
do you wish to speak on your
uh yes uh very briefly um thank you very
much I really appreciate um
representative uh
Darby's intent on the bill I completely
sympathize with uh the idea of wanting
more local
control um and trying to approach the
the uh problem in this manner he rep
representative did did a good job with
um working out the public hearing
process but um I have to speak um
unfortunately against it on the basis of
what the assistant commissioner Eddie
Edwards said that the Department's
current resources within the Bureau of
hearings to implement the pro pro uh
policy are inadequate um and um I'd like
to probably speak with the
representative um just based on my
experience with um being in a a plan and
working on the planning department in a
town and filling out um and carrying out
the public hearing process of of uh you
know sending out um uh mailings um for
notifications on
hearings um this although he had the the
representative had a a lot of good
points in here uh it's very difficult
for a private citizen to carry this out
um
uh and
to document the um the mailings being
certified mail they have to uh hold on
to those um receipts for the certified
mailings and then if there's a a problem
with it they have to uh um there there
has to be a process for in a butter to
say hey I didn't get my mail um and then
also like possibly an appeals process um
I think Pro possibly the it's a a the
intent is really I I appreciate the
intent and possibly we can find a way to
do this in another more streamlined
fashion and that's all thank
you representative wolf to speak the
second thank you um I'm opposed to this
for another reason that I don't believe
was mentioned if we truly believe that
the lakes are all held in trust for
everybody why should 25 people be able
to have a hearing to restrict
something and the person next
door the 26th house up wants to have
that I'm very opposed to
spot I guess I'll call it spot Zoning
for any other
reason um if we're going to do it do it
for the whole lake don't do it for this
area and that and not for that area um
so I don't like the idea that we will
have
varying spots on the lake and for that
reason I'm voting against this
bill anyone else to speak on the bill
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
I don't want to go on for five hours
which I could easily do on this bill but
I uh first I'll just reply very quickly
to um my colleagues concerns I'll note
that
um the notification language in the law
regarding horsepower and um horsepower
and speed limit restrictions already
which which they there are a few of
these per year you can go on the website
already requires exactly the same
requirement actually a slightly minor
requirement but it does
require um a certified maale of 25 um
sorry of everyone that's affected um in
fact the the quarter mile the butter
definition comes exactly from that um
statue with respect to um uh hearings in
general hearings are a very well
established process by the department of
safety they're done uh numerous times a
year for moins they also require 25 um
25 uh petitioners um the fact that 20
what what came up a lot in testimony on
this bill was 25 people can ban um the
um you know can ban the sport can ban
the activity that's that's not true at
all um the specifically um the
department of safety has to take in um
the fact that take into account during
the the petition during the hearing
process and during the decision- making
that the um that the what body of water
is a public resource and everyone has
access to it um and they have to find
they have to have a number of different
findings in order to determine that
there's a real reason for this but
mostly what I'd like to
say um is that there's a lot of talk
we've talked a lot in this committee
we've heard a lot we've heard we've got
a presentation in front of us about the
differences between Senate bills and
various bills and there's some some some
people are starting to coales around
distances and I get distances but what
we'll see again and again is that
distances doesn't cover depth we heard
um we heard very compelling testimony
from a um a member on
um the Lake's not in front of me where
half the lake is only wiip pocket lake
where half the lake is only 10 ft deep
and because they're WG surfing in that
portion of the lake that's why they're
they're having such
disturbances so um so what this would
allow is that because we because the
department of safety very clearly came
out and said we're worried about um
trying to enforce depth restrictions
this would allow those very sensitive
shallow areas 10 feet depths um to be to
be
managed we heard of course that people
say oh you can't um WG surf in 10 ft
well if that were the case um we
wouldn't have we we wouldn't have had
the problems we're seeing in wiip pocket
and um in a number of other shallow
Lakes I I I could go on for a long long
time about um about you know the the the
the testimony we heard but I've outlaid
my outlined my major points on this uh
on this sheet that I put in front of you
and I'd also like to say that on the
back of that sheet um describes the
amendment and it describes how why the
amendment addresses the concerns about
the um about the hearings process we did
apparently we did get a letter from um
uh assistant commissioner Edwards about
1301 I personally never saw it it wasn't
presented during testimony I never got
it in my email to tell you the truth I
was frustrated that to hear about it
this morning um but but we apparently we
did but that was before this amendment
and I'll just point out in particular
here that the amendment includes
language that allows the department of
safety to Define rules for when the
hearings can take place um and those
rules will allow them to basically space
these out on a time frame that meets
their schedule so that they don't have
to hire um additional hearings officers
we didn't get a letter following that I
did I did speak with I did speak with
attorney Casco the hearings um the
bureau chief um for hearing
um about my Amendment we did not get a
letter back after um of the impacts
after this
amendment so I know I've already gone on
too long I would I wake surfing is of
serious concern across the state serious
concern it is damaging the ecosystem and
it is damaging people's um people's low
impact uses of the lake and I would urge
you to um vote against this itm motion
thank
you
representative yeah representative I'm
just looking for other okay thank you Mr
chair I'm also going to oppose the itl
um with great respect for my colleague
um representative wolf when we talk
about 25 people submitting a petition
these are people who live around the
lake or on the lake and they are the
first people that are going to observe
damage or concern and this is a way for
them to bring that forward and have an
objective hearing officer look at all of
the considerations and make a
determination each one of our lakes in
New Hampshire and our rivers are
different from each other and um I think
this addresses the uniqueness of each
Lake um this this hearing process rather
than having some blanket regulation
across the state um this is really
taking into account the depth um we've
heard testimony from divers from that
diver who has saw a significant damage
to the bottom of the lake from Wake
boats um I heard from a constituent last
night who lives on babusek lake in
miramac who has also seen significant
damage from Wake boats have we heard
from people from Deep Lakes no it's not
an issue there so I don't see that
there's a problem enjoy the Wake boats
um but I think when they are placed on
these very specific lakes that are
brought to the attention by people who
witness it um I think this bill helps us
identify those problem areas and bring
remediation so
um I I guess I I think that hearing
process we have to look at that as a way
way of really pinpointing areas in our
state where restrictions on Wake boats
because of the damage they're doing
should be considered thank
you anyone else to speak representative
L
mon I yes um well I I agree with
representative wolf that it would be um
we ought to pass um Statewide um
statutes about weight surfing if we're
going to have to do that um I also agree
with representative Rong and
representative Darby that there will be
um small bodies of water where even if
we pass other legislation which I think
we're likely to do um there will be some
bodies of water where the
local um
conditions
um there it's going to it's not going to
fall under the um the broader statute
that we passed and that um people should
be able to bring forward a petition
specifically to protect that body of
water and as far as overwhelming um the
department of safety with petitions I
think likely that since we are we'll
probably get some sort of
distance uh restrictions passed either
with the Senate bill or 139
that that will take care of most of the
petitions I think it would end up being
a smaller number that actually have to
or it would take care of the need for
more petitions and it would be only a
small number of lakes that feel a need
to bring a specific petition forward so
I'm going to be voting against the
itl anyone else
representative thank you Mr chair I to
will be voting against the itl for a
couple of reasons um this is a different
approach than bills that we've had in
the past and it is in keeping with what
New Hampshire Dees has been saying with
us down the line which defining the
activity rather than the watercraft and
looking at um the situation
from an environmental impact um we
shouldn't be ruling that out and we
shouldn't be ruling that in um the
problems that we're having with the
lakes and the C bacteria and the
flooding um are all contributing to some
serious conditions on the lakes and
those conditions as we know with cyano
bacteria really On The Rise can
critically impact um our state's economy
so I'm glad that we're looking at this
and we're moving forward with it and I
hope to see more discussion of this bill
as it makes its way through the
legislature um and I'm hoping that we
can defeat the itl so that we can bring
a motion of um a to pass as amended I
think I received an
amendment and anyone else wish to
speak represent representative of
wolf thank you Mr
chairman I'm opposing this bill because
and maybe I shouldn't be talking about
the amendment at this time but the bill
the I
will the wording in the bill allows 25
or more residents of property own of a
town they don't even have to be on the
lake and there are some other places in
here
that I don't think are correct but
that's a big one and as I said before
it's a spot zoning that gets to
me I I'll surprise some people with some
other votes down the line but this one
is a spot zoning Bill and I'm against it
for that very reason I understand
representative
Darby's six comments or something in
there and I appreciate you making them
but it's still to me and we have had
situations on our Lake I'm on sopy been
there for too many years to
remember but we don't Scot zone out and
there've been a number of hearings that
the department Department of Safety is
held up there and they have all not spot
zoned that's my problem with this
bill anyone
else where are
we on the motion to
itl Noone else wishes to speak will the
clerk please call the
rooll thank you uh representative harb
yes representative G yes representative
Horgan yes votes yes representative
Healey yes representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative dun yes
representative Vale no representative
rung no representative Kelly no
representative Simpson no representative
Baldwin no representative Derby no
Representative hoit
no Representative lontine no
representative
lit representative Malloy no and the
chair
yes that is 1010
motion motion fails for is
1010 is there another
motion representative Darby I'd like to
make a motion of odd to pass on House
Bill 1301 motion of ought to pass so I
have a second representative rung for a
second you like to speak to your motion
I'd like to make a motion uh to amend
House Bill uh 1309 with Amendment
2024 d11
07h do I have a second to the amendment
representative rung seconds the
amendment would you like to speak to
your Amendment representative G
yes thank you Mr chair very briefly this
amendment which um is bulleted out on
the back of the handout that I provided
addresses the primary concerns that we
heard during testimony over um over the
hearing
process I think I've said enough on uh
the remainder of the Bill thank
you you like to speak to your second yes
Mr chair thank you I want to thank
representative Darby for the amendment
it does address many of the concerns
that were brought up
with the in the public hearing and I
think it makes the bill better and um
more responsive to concerns thank
you anyone anyone else wish to speak on
the amendment on the
amendment seeing none on the amendment
will the clerk please call the role yes
thank you on the amendment
Representative harb
no representative gold no representative
Horgan no
votes no representative Healey no
representative wolf no representative
MCU no representative Donnelly no
representative dun no representative
Vale yes representative Rong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin
yes representative Derby yes
representative Hoy yes resentative L
montine yes representative lit yes
representative Moy yes and the
chair no it's 101 1010 the motion on the
amendment
fails on the motion of ought to
pass wish to speak on a motion of ought
to
pass the Bill still stands um as uh in
the bill still provides the same hearing
process as exists for um a combination
of wake um horsepower and um speed limit
restrictions and the um and
um ski craft restrictions both that have
hearing processes so the these uh the
hearing process that uh is in the
original bill um is already in existing
statute and so I see no reason not to
pass the bill as is and I urge you to
vote ought to pass on 1301 thank
you wish to speak to your second yes
thank you Mr chair um I want to just
repeat what representative Darby said
we've already had this longstanding
statute this is just adding wake boats
to it and I think considering the
environmental damage they're causing to
shallow areas of our Lakes it's very
important that we get something in that
would include this weight boats as well
as existing um subjects as far as
horsepower goes and those other things
that fall under that hearing statute
thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
motion of ought to pass seeing
none cler please call the rooll on a to
pass a to pass on 1301 representative
Harbor
no representative gold no representative
organ no Quotes no representative hey no
representative wolf no representative M
no Representative johnell no
representative dun no representative
Vale yes representative rang yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yeses FL yes
representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Malloy yes and the
chair no that's 1010 it's 1010 we
are at a deadlock the the only other
thing we could do is a motion to interim
study but I don't think that's going to
go very far
so which case declare a uh a no
recommendation so it goes to the floor
any any comments on
that representative
Bale thank you Mr chair um yes I think
this should come to the floor there's a
lot of people involved that will want to
have something to say and the general
membership will want to hear what we've
been doing in the committee so far okay
there is a requirement for a anyone else
wish to speak
for there the notion so the committee is
no recommendation and there will be a a
for and
against uh the the aop pass will be the
uh uh will be the what's what's what's
accept what's acceptable well the way it
goes to the floor it's automatic a the
pass represent representative Derby will
per have write the majority can I ask or
WR the put it this way right
the can ask a question the four yes can
we include the amendment in the um
calendar rather than on the floor uh it
is in the it would be I think it would
does go on the calendar because it was
voted okay thank
you uh and uh yeses representative
Harvey bolia for uh
against
okay
and okay
oh that takes care of
1390 are we going to break for
lunch lunch okay well well you have uh
we do have people here we're only we
still have halfway to go uh do I'll put
it to the the do you like to say a half
hour lunch you've G down and get
something fast huh I
mean no all right all in favor signify
by put it this way all those who want to
go to lunch leave we'll keep
[Laughter]
going that's fine I'm just going to go
to the men's room then thank
you okay I mean
well right now we're at uh 13 we're
we're going 1390 we have 9 one 2 3 4
five we're
halfway break for half an hour thank
you
huhs to
go
maybe sometimes some people sometimes
some people you call for a break some
people don't understand what you do all
right I'm going to call we're going to
recess till 20 after
1 and we're going to start
back Mr chairman can we make that 45
minutes there there is a lunch for some
of
us as you may remember going on right
now oh recall there was a meeting in
rep's Hall and then a lunch at up and
Walker yeah that some members may want
to attend it was it was partisan all
right 45 minutes I I'll go with 45
minutes that's what time anytime you
know anytime there's free food I will
never
stop
[Music]
e
for
uh where
is M MCH
again or is he still get let's see if
he's let me call let me give a call to
him can you text Mr M did
you you can do it oh we can do both hey
you don't want one of took
off
okay uh
the yeah well you're the one that went
to the entertainment Joe
now time to come back to the other
entertainment oh you won't have
to it's she wants it itl
so
yep well you
I I
Pro I want to recognize it yep byebye
bye he he went he be right
over he's still being entertained that
the
Republicans well well I won't worry
about
that
uh instead of going
to I am going to for R for this
till Q comes in I think I'll just uh I'm
going to go jump over to uh
149 oh there he is okay let's open the
hearing
on House Bill
1390 and uh recog
ni repres
representative representative
harb thank been a long day and I didn't
get much sleep thank you Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion to itl HB
1390 is there a
second I was trying to jump
in okay
uh
we're in the I know you're tell what
you're looking you the question that I'm
asking is can this bill be postponed to
next week I know the other Bill the
other one was voted down was that for
all postponements or for that specific
bill that was for that specific one
because uh there was an issue on uh well
you heard the issue right this one this
one is different
this is different this is a different
Bill well I'm
requesting that this bill be postponed
till next
week when you could you could explain
why we we have a uh an amendment it just
came back from
oll there's some errors in it um and uh
I'd like to get it corrected so that we
can present a good clean
bill
uh I'm going to make this decision as
chair I'll I'll let go ahead I'll would
you want
to say something I'll I'll listen to but
I'm not I don't want to put this to a
discussion but I just want to say I
support representative Wolf's idea of
postponing the bill I think we heard a
lot of of testimony and there are a
couple amendments that are coming in and
I think we could use some more
time I'm I'm the I'm and I'm going to
make this a as a
chair I I see how these bills are going
no Amendment my belief is going to
change anybody's Minds so let's let's
bite the bullet and put it to and put it
all to put it to a vot
uh I I'd be very surprised if any if
this isn't if uh this is not
a well let's just say I let's just send
it to send it to the
Flor okay all
right but let's why we continue yeah
yeah all right
so Mr chair I think I need a second on
my motion to
IDL second thank you m representative
MCH second uh is there do you wish to
speak on your motion yes I'll speak
briefly on my motion
um I'm concerned in this bill about the
depth issue about the shoreline issue
about all the maps and plans we sh saw
that would probably send a whole bunch
of boats and to a
particular uh Lake because they can't
ride on another Lake and then there
there's going to be congestion traffic I
also saw the um testimony that was
submitted uh regarding the inability of
uh the Marine Patrol to uh figure depths
and to test depths and what happens that
the depths change so for that reason I
don't think this bill as they say is
ready for prime time that's why I moved
uh to itl it I also believe that if
there are amendments and things that uh
the representatives on this committee
think might be applicable to wake
surfing I'm told that uh the Senate Bill
431 will come to us and and that might
be the time to bring all these other
amendments in for Senate 31 43 one thank
you representative
M thank you Mr chairman I'll support the
motion of itl I'm a lifelong Boer and in
depths change every day some are known
only to the local
boter we heard from the Marine Patrol
would be almost impossible to enfor
enforce any depth provision it would
cost a massive amount of money and
personnel and resources and be difficult
to educate the public in terms of depth
restrictions additionally we'd be out
long an entire entire classes of boats
and I heard representatives from this
committee say just earlier today that we
should be concerned about the behavior
not the specific
watercraft uh that very often boats
other than wake boats will put off large
wakes I've experienced that myself and
it's annoying uh and it could be
damaging it's that behavior that we
should enforce um not a specific class
of boat or single out a specific Sport
and cause significant e economic damage
to our tourism industry and make us the
only um such a restrictive state in New
England we just it would just really be
bad for the state so I'll support the
itel for those reasons there two other
states anyone else wish to speak
representative Derby then representative
lante uh thank you Mr chair just to
correct the record um the the bill um at
1390 as passed actually is in a or in is
in um Place same restrictions are in
place in Vermont so it wouldn't be the
only state in New England but more to my
the point that I really want to make is
that um we know that cyano bacteria is
causing havoc on our Lakes we know that
uh wig surfing is not the only source of
that cyano bacteria nobody would ever
presume that we just we just passed a
bill I think we passed the bill to uh
just recommended the bill to deal with
um septics as a as a source of that
cyano bacteria we passed a bill earlier
we recommended a bill earlier passed on
consent to treat Lakes to treat lakes
with aluminum because we know how much
of phosphorus is coming out of the
sediment
itself we know this committee knows that
the sediment contains phosphorus yet
we're willing to let boats uh and in uh
uh eject this sediment into the um into
the water water column the chief aquatic
biologist of Dees testified that leg
phosphorus um can be measured to have
been increased 20% um due to sediment
disturbance caused by wake surfing in uh
Waters Body Waters of water less than 20
feet so not considering uh not
considering depth is is um is just the
wrong approach uh we we need to take
every
um every effect we can in order to fight
cyano bacteria it's poisoning our legs
it's po it's poisoning our animals it's
poisoning our residents thank you I I
urge you to vote against the
itl anyone else wish to speak
oh
sores yes the Wake sports are um not the
only reason people come to enjoy the New
Hampshire Lakes and I think it's really
important that we keep them healthy and
also um we're not Banning wake surfing
the idea of the bill is to impose some
restrictions so that other users of the
lake um can have their interest and how
they enjoy the lake also protected um in
addition to the environmental concerns
and I think we should oppose the itl
because there are some amendments that
will will address some of the
concerns and I don't believe that um it
would be so expensive and impossible to
um Define depths on a lake every Lake
Association knows how deep the water is
and various locations it would be very
easy to put up buoy markers defining no
wake zones at any
Lake um so I think we
should um not it the bill and allow
another motion and amendments to come
forward representative
Bale thank you Mr chair and in the
interest of time I did bring an
amendment um and I second what has
already been said in opposition to the
itl
representative I didn't I keep hear
seeing people pointing you but I'm not
seeing you looking at me so all right do
then then then representative
W thank
you I think I'm gonna go quickly first
okay um I'm G to be voting against the
itl I'm one of those people who uh wants
to vote for a compromise Amendment
whether it's in the house or something
we Reed from the Senate um I hope we'll
get a bill from the Senate but I don't
want to count on that so I'll um vote
against this and hope to have the chance
to vote on a compromise
Amendment representative
w i uh second representative Simpson's
uh comments originally I was going to
vote against this bill 500 ft was just
too much for me to accept but we I've
worked it down to a couple of amendments
and I'd like to move forward and have
the opportunity to amend amend the bill
representative hey and I were talking
about an average depth on certain
Lakes um and there may be some other
stuff unfortunately I don't have the
luxury and we're going to have to go
with what I have
today but there is a need to do
something and I'm not going to let the
perfect be the enemy of the
good let's try and get something through
so that we don't screw it up for our
kids and our
grandkids the cob bacteria and the
pollution isn't going to happen in the
next year or two or
three but it's like the changing
temperatures and people can't tell you
tell me that I'm going to
believe that we're not seeing change in
climate and temperature I know when I
get out of my sugar house I'm starting
in two months earlier than I used
to that warmth is going to affect the
lakes and it's going to affect the
ability to use the
lakes and I would like to see something
get pasted I don't know I have my
amendments here but we have to get off
and try to find a
compromise please don't let it just go
down the road marine industries has been
working with compromise
we've been working let's do something
I'm going to vote against the
itl anyone else to speak represent
representative rang then
representative thank you Mr chair I also
want to remind the committee of the
testimony we received which I found very
compelling from The Loon conservation
committee or loon preservation committee
um and also from the diver who has gone
under um and seeing the damage this is
causing in Shallow areas um throughout
New Hampshire um last night I received
an email from a constituent in miramac
who is a diver also and noted the damage
from Wake boats so I agree with my
colleague from Newbury that we we can't
kick the can down the road and I'm
willing to look at a compromise as well
to address a lot of these issues I also
want to challenge the assumption that by
restricting weight boats in certain
areas is going to have an economic
impact because anecdotally I hear from
people who don't want to be on the Lakes
because of the Wake booat so that's
economic value that we're going to lose
because of them so without a objective
comprehensive financial
analysis um I I don't think it's fair to
say that there will be an economic
impact thank
you is that at a
point I agree with representative
wol um I also think that if if Vermont
is going to be passing laws to restrict
they're going to send all all of our all
of their boers that they can't use their
lakes and and if we're not prepared for
that we're going to have a whole lot
more
boats and no restrictions keep them
under control so I agree we should do
this and we should do it
quickly thank you any anyone else to
speak on the
motion itl representative Donnelly um I
just would like to talk briefly about
the what representative talked about and
that is we're talking about a behavior
and now we're we're I'm for the itl due
to the fact that we're specifying a
craft and not the behavior so um my
frustration with this bill is the way it
has been presented to go after one
specific uh
craft and it really what we're
complaining about is has to do with the
waves and things in that for the last
two days I live on the lake the waves
that have been coming because of the
wind have been amazing in what they've
done for destroying and and and making
lots of damage against the the shoreline
so I think we've done a lot of good
bills in here that could do the could do
really good things I think this this
this bill um has flaws due to the fact
that it's specifying a specific boat at
a specific
um when it's at a specific um I'll say
plane so it's at when it's creating it's
four- foot wake and things of that
nature so there was a lot of good
testimony and going back to the Loon
preservation they only mentioned that
there was nothing about I because I
asked that specific question uh you know
what's what's the distance and all they
said is you have to look at the loons
behavior and that's true for any boting
so we should ban all boats then on all
lakes because bons on them I mean I I
think we have to be cognizant of our of
our Wildlife absolutely but there
shouldn't be that testimony didn't
really pan out um in my in my opinion
for that specific reason um thank
you anyone
else speak on the motion motion of itl
for the C please call the
rooll yes thank you Mr chair on heal
1390 motion of itl repres harp yes
representative gold yes representative
Horan yes CL votes yes representative
Healey yes representative
wolf
no representative MCU
yes representative Donnelly
yes representative dun
yes representative Vale
no representative rang no
representative
Kelly
no representative Simpson
no representative Baldwin no
representative Derby no Representative
hoit no Representative lontine
no representative love it
no and representative Malloy
no and the chair
yes n 9
N wa a minute n No it should be 911 911
is that right y
yeah 9 to1 9 to1 9 to1 motion fails I
have another
motion repres
representative
Bale thank you Mr chair I move ought to
pass on House Bill 13 I make a motion of
ought to pass for 1390
okay and I have an amendment okay for
for a second on the motion okay
represent L mon seconds uh do you wish
to speak oh me you do have an it's open
to
Amendment and you have an amendment for
yes I make a motion of a to pass as
amended or moving the amendment moving
Amendment 2024
you have copies of
that I put those on everyone's desk
during the break oh uh it should be in
your papers on your desk and there's a
few copies by representative Derby I've
already read
it
am that be good representative wol can
we see your Amendment two so we know
like we don't have people are
offering yes I
apologize
well you only look at one Amendment at a
time oh this
is right but I mean we can we can only
take on one
Amendment what's wrong with
this I I don't have I don't have
a you put it on everybody's desk a
little
one is it that's 1390 oh this is it oh
yeah okay oh
oh oh right okay so you can just have
that 1085 and 1108 are the two
amendments that you should
have you have
one
this okay 10 is 1085 and right now the
motion on the amendment is on 11 8
1108 okay everybody anybody need a
chance to read
it only have
sentence ready all right you wish to
speak on your on your
Amendment yes I would in the original
bill um the wakes Sport
Zone um the area where it says wakes wak
Sports shall not be
permitted it says on the original bill
on a body of water smaller than 50
contiguous Acres that was
removed um on the distance from
Shoreline that was reduced from 500 ft
to 300 50 ft and the waters less than 20
ft deep was left the same so I just
brought this forward to see if people
would be more apt to
support different limits than the ones
that were in the original
Bill who seconded
that then wish to speak and your
second
yes I think this is um a reasonable
compromise and that
um I'll repeat what other people have
said I think it's really important that
we do
something and to just let this go
another year um we're likely to have
more damage and yes of
course some some of these restrictions
will mean that some parts of lakes or
small lakes and
ponds would mean there is no wake Sport
Zone on that particular body of water
but that is necessary if we're going to
protect the water
quality and protect other people's
enjoyment of the lake and I think the
depth is a really important component of
this as we heard a lot of testimony
about how much
damage the Wake surface
does to the stirring up the settlement
in Shallow
Waters so I'm going to vote for this
amendment representative uh Derby point
of order if we we're voting on this
amendment y can another amendment be
introduced after this even if this
passes uh yes it can
however uh whatever the amendment the
First Amendment is if the second the
Second
Amendment same thing I understand yes I
understand how one can supersede the
other I just want to make sure that the
another someone else can make a motion
um to introduce Amendment even if this
passes okay thank
you
representative
Bale thank you Mr chair um thank you for
indulging me if I might ask a question
of Representative wolf go right
ahead I happy happily be
indulged you look
it I just want to make sure that were
you planning to introduce this today to
make make a motion yes yes ma'am because
I do prefer your Amendment thank
you I withdraw yours and I'll put this
one
in we are not you know we hav been
voting if you wish to withdraw your
amendment I do thank you and thank you
for thank you to representative wolf for
coming up with a better amendment I
withdraw my motion yes yeah does this a
second withdraw their
Amendment does a second withdraw their
Amendment love agree to
withdraw you don't have if you don't
then it becomes your
Amendment okay I'll withdraw it okay I'd
like to make an amendment then all right
well we the motion with the amendment is
withdrawn for a motion to amend I'd like
to make an
amendment 2024
d185 and I'd like to speak to my
amendment is there a second I'll second
that
representative we sit
here and make
laws for not individuals but for the
greater good of the State of New
Hampshire and somebody's going to get
scorched and I feel badly about
that but there are more people that are
going to
benefit by doing something
about this problem that these boats are
creating we have a lot of people that
enjoy them and we have haven't
eliminated them by my motion I want them
to be able to go out and enjoy
themselves on the Lakes I want those
gentlemen over there to be able to
continue to sell
boats in Havens but at the same time I
don't want to
see our Lakes turned into where those
weed whacking machines are employed
fulltime they're not the only cause of
this the problems here
we have septic systems we have high
winds we have a lot of things but unless
we pick some of the things that we can
do something
about we're going to lose our ability to
enjoy the
Lakes I have put this bill forward and
I've reduced it down to something that I
think I know what it is and maybe you
people are all smarter than I am but 300
ft is a football field so I know how far
out I have to be it's not 350 not 400
it's it's a football
field a smaller Lake of 50 acres that's
what's been in here and
determined I have not put in a
depth requirement because basically if
you're out 300 fet you're going to be
over 15 ft of water and that's where my
people at the lake cipy protective
Association tells me it's a
minimum now they're going to be some
areas that are going to get
eroded no there's nothing I can do about
it I'm looking for the greater good I'm
looking to preserve the lake Lakes
plural for
those that are my children and my
grandchildren
is it perfect no it isn't and Andy
excuse me represented Mr chairman if I
had another week I probably couldn't
make it much better so this is the one
that I want to move forward and if you
people feel it's up to the the group on
the other side of the wall that's fine
too we can take the two bills and put
them
together but if we don't do something
and start the ball rolling
today it's going to be that much
worse a year two years three years and
will it be able to turn around I hope
so but when we had a record warmth in
February I wonder whether we're going to
be able to turn the climate
around this is a climate to me and it's
time to do something before it's too
late I hope will pass this amendment and
then pass the bill so that we can move
forward and make what necessary changes
we have to
make thank you for giving me the
opportunity thank Mr chairman thank
representative wolf for bringing this
amendment that addresses the depth
issue addresses the small body of water
issue that we heard from our Marat
constituents uh this will be a step
forward forward the the Senate Bill
language is very close to this um I
think it's 250 ft um and also 200 or two
200 thank you so it's it's quite quite
close to this so I might still prefer
that language but this is a good step
for sure so I thank representative wolf
for bringing this forward uh I think it
it helps out our our marac constituents
and all of our constituents that have
the small body of water issue especially
uh so for those reasons I I support this
it still doesn't address the the
behavior so I think it's a it's a good
first step and I'd encourage the Marine
Patrol to address that with you know no
wake zones where it's necessary and they
can do that on an ongoing basis Lake by
Lake um I have a little concern on the
fiscal note you know if they were to
need funding to put buoys out but those
are things they can ask for on an
ongoing basis um but this brings us a
step closer to solving the problem and a
step closer um
in you know from this committee's
position anyway so thank you
representative wolf and I encourage you
to support this amendment and then ought
to pass as amended
thanks thank
you thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative wolf for being this um I
think it's a step in the right direction
because any step forward is going to be
helpful um and I also think that
bringing the setback to 300 feet is
important because in in some of our
small lakes and in my community babus
lake is 228 Acres but having 300 ft um
it will prevent wake boats I I don't
know if there how much room there is
between each Shore but it we could have
lakes that are greater than 50 acres but
still wake boats would be restricted
because they wouldn't be able to pass
down the center of the lake and still
clear 300 ft from each side but um I'm
I'm glad you did this I think it's a
great compromise and I'm going to be
supporting it thank
you oops
yeah so mine is on not working at
all check everybody oh I'm back you
never know there's somebody watching
what we're doing and they're not in the
room things can
happen I get to start over um yeah this
so this has been you know this has been
going on it's a long process uh we heard
testimony that it's been 5 years that
people have been bringing up wake Sports
as an as something that they feel needs
to be addressed and um throughout the
day today here we've spoken about a lot
of environmental concerns and you've
heard me say the words cumulative
impacts over and over we really have to
look at everything that's happening on
the Lakes all sports probably impact the
lake we can't say that you know one
one particular crowd or one particular
activity is really doing all of the
damage that's not but in the end what we
need to do is have a compromise so that
the people can coexist and when we had
the um the hearings last week in rep's
Hall we heard from someone who came in
and he said wait a minute now we this is
the water is held in the public trust
and we all get to use it so as long as
um we're continuing to work
with this with all the people that and
the stakeholders that have come to the
table so far I think we will come to a
compromise I'm not sure this is it but
I'm proud that we're working on it so
thank
you thank you Mr chair I think the last
statements of my fellow representative
Veil tells you why I'm going to vote
against the
amendment I'm not sure this is the
amendment that should be passed uh I
appreciate that it needed to be worked
on some more um so that's number one
number two I I am from a town which is
only one of two towns in the entire
state that has no standing body of water
so yes plasto New Hampshire so uh I'm
sort of unbiased here because I can't
get in trouble with any of my
constituents because we don't have a
standing body of water but I I listen to
all the testimony I listen about the
wind I listen about the um ice the lack
of ice the more ice um I I listen
to the speed of the Wake boats I don't
have a boat so I look you know how fast
do they go we're not talking about the
um cigarette boats in Miami you know
it's a boat I'm told that doesn't go too
fast and um so I I listen to all this
and I think yes I I those of you that
know me I'm always the great compromiser
which is why I looked at the Senate bill
and I mentioned that before I said well
maybe the Senate Bill's got something
that we can play with send back to the
Senate and compromise with the Senate um
so for those Reasons I'm not opposed to
doing something this isn't the thing I
think I can support in the future I
might be able to support something else
so I'm going to vote against the
amendment although I might be as
representative Darby says once in a
while and the
minority thank
you anyone else representative Derby
thank you Mr chair so you know I've
already made my um my note my intent
about how how important depth is known
so I won't repeat those arguments I will
say that the the specific cases that we
heard where people are being directly
impacted wiip pocket lake um babusek
Lake Arlington Pond none of those are
going to be saved by this bill you can
look at the depth Maps I've got them up
on my screen right now um they all have
they're all less than 20 ft for the vast
majority of the lake and they all have
um they're all more than about a
thousand feet wide so we can vote for
this bill but we're still going to
poison those
ponds represent representative
Lon well I do agree that it's um it is a
start and there's no guarantee that the
Senate bill is going to pass so I think
we should keep moving forward with this
and there's always opportunity to
compromise or have a conference
to um produce a better bill but um as to
those other ponds let's hope that your
bill will has a chance of passing
because that's the only way some of
those other ponds and small lakes might
be able to protect themselves since they
clearly won't be protected by this
restriction and it is just a restri
restriction and it is restricting the
weight Sports activity wake boo is
defined in the bill but it is about the
activity not a particular boat that's
being
restricted anyone else representative M
for a second time thanks and I'll just
be really brief I may agree with
representative harb that some of the
Senate Bill aspects or we may have to
change just like small things like the
effective date because it happens the be
in the middle of the summer which could
be problematic so we may have to tweak
that using the Senate bill or maybe even
ask the Senate to amend it further but
it's a good step it's a good step
forward so and anyways
thanks anyone else wish to speak on the
issue on the on the
amendment will the clerk please call the
role uh on the uh amendment of 1085 for
House Bill 1390 ought to pass Rob
representative har
no representative
ghouls no representative Horan no no
representative Healey
yes representative wolf yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly no
repres uh representative dun
no representative ill
yes representative rung
yes representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby
no uh representative Point
yes representative L montain yes
herbs and of love it
yes hers of Malloy yes and the chair no
okay that's
127 motion
pass there that's that's for the
amendment aren't there
20 I got
128 oh I'm sorry eight I'm sorry 128 128
C that was on all
right on ought to pass with
Amendment who wish to speak on see
who is the maker still representative
Veil even though her motion was you're
maker of the uh about the pass
correct
you no you have to
well excuse
me I have nothing further Mr chair on
the motion I think we've had a robust um
discussion thus
far was it
second representative L Montaine you
wish to speak on the Au to pass as
amended no I just hope that we pass
this any anyone else wish to speak on
the bill I thought the pass has amended
seeing no one will the clerk please call
the
role um to passes Amendment 1390
representative harp no representative G
no representative Horgan no clerk votes
no representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
mq yes representative Donnelly no
representative dun
no representative Veil
yes representative Rong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Malloy yes and the
chair
no that is
seven motion passes
13 Mr chair for a point of order oh
shoot I I think on the last Amendment Mr
Wolf's Amendment it was mentioned it was
128 I don't think it was 128 just for
the record I thought it was
137 three no well no it was Derby voted
against Derby voted against thank you
thank you for the clarification I'm
getting tired here
too all right
uh we'll write the uh majority
report okay 13 it's the representative
har but you write the
minority is there a minority for we need
huh I can write one yeah well I can't
happy to write a minority Mr chair yes
may I thank this
committee for their Fair
honest and thinking for the people of
the State of New Hampshire approach to
this bill it's been a pleasure to
discuss it with you thank
you okay moving right on we're
on House Bill
94 here recognizes representative
Kelly thank you Mr chair I move off to
pass on HB 1494 and I'd like to
introduce an
amendment do we have a second for
representative
Kelly seconded by representative Derby
and you have an amendment what amendment
uh are you I do
it is amendment number
138h I distributed it before we started
today so you should all have it in front
of
you hey I found
it and so I moved to amend the bill you
move to amend the your
second thank you representative Darby
seconds wish to speak to the amendment
yes thank you Mr chair so as I uh talked
about in our public hearing um this
amendment will remove sections one two
and five from from the original bill um
those are the sections that we heard
testimony against during the public
hearing um so that what remains is
section three and four this amendment
also
um places the language from what was
section 4 into uh both snowmobiles and
ohvs so that the language is uh
continuous across both um and those are
the two changes that the amendment
does anyone wish to oh representative
Derby to speak on your uh second I just
want a second uh representative Kelly's
um Mo uh comments and say that this
addresses the um you know the
deficiencies of the original Bill and in
um really closes a couple of loopholes
that have been found from what I
understand from the ohrv committee so um
I urge every I urge the committee to
vote uh yes to adopt the amendment thank
you representative Vale speak on the
motion on the
amendment thank you Mr chair um the
amendment addresses the concerns that
were raised and I will be voting in
favor of the amendment thank
you any anyone else wishes to speak on
the
amendment if not on the amendment will
the clerk please call the
role on the amendment representative
harb
yes representative G yes representative
Horan yes clerk votes yes representative
Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
Miku yes representative
donelly yes okay representative dun yes
representative
Vil you can just
say go like
that she go votes
yes representative Veil votes
yes um representative run yes
representative Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative L yes representative
Malloy
yes and shair
yes 20 to
zero you wish to speak on your bill as
the pass as
amended yeah as I I will I'll let what I
already said go go as said um there's
not much more to add thank you
representative Derby nothing further
thank you I'm I'm shocked who
took you're you're all talked out
no
okay
well anyone else wish to speak on the
ought to pass as amended if not look CL
please call the
role um on a to pass as amended House
Bill
representative
yes representative gold yes represent
organ yes cler votes yes representative
hey yes representative wolf yes
representative Miku yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale yes representative
Rong yes representative Kelly yes
representative sson yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Derby yes
representative F yes representative
lontine yes yes representative L yes
representative Malloy yes and the chair
yes 20 to zero motion pass zero motion
passed
CC yep okay all right so motion
uh House
Bill
153 which
is I
first so all of these amendments here
I've lost my
calendar you have
the what's 1503 is it the it's 153 yep
what is it Rel to the definition of wet
relative to the definition of wetlands
do I have a
motion motion from representative Derby
yes thank you Mr chair I'd like to make
a motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1503
motion is there a
second seconded by representative Kelly
you'd like to speak to your
motion what do you think Mr chair
yes my apologies my apologies for the
humor um it but thank you Mr chair I I
um as we heard in testimony wetlands are
is a scientifically defined term and New
Hampshire shouldn't try to define the
term itself as it does in this bill in
fact Wetlands is used the term is the
definition is used Nationwide and it
would there would be um implications in
terms of uh interacting with um the the
federal statutes if we tried to redefine
Wetlands um and uh Department of
Environmental Services it was very
sympathetic to you know recognizing that
sometimes there needs to be exclusions
to um to permitting for wetlands in fact
we talked about one of those earlier
today um that I voted for um and they
suggested the permitting should be um
based on the activities rather than
redefining the terms so for all of those
reasons and others that I'm sure you
don't want me to go into I urge you to
um vote inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1503 thank
you where was who who
seconded president Kelly you wish to
speak on
no let we'll do the speaking thank
you representative
Bale thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
add to um what representative Darby said
that you know I don't think that this
bill would have solved the problem that
the sponsor was trying to
address and for that reason I'll be
voting in support of the
itto anyone else wish to speak on the
bill
on the motion the
it if not clerk please call the
rooll on motion of itl House Bill 1503
representative harp
yes representative gold yes
representative Horgan yes CL votes
yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
MCU yes representative donelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vil yes representative run yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative ltin yes
representative lit yes representative
Malloy yes and the chair yes to zero
motion
passes motion passes
itl moving on content calendar yeah said
calendar calendar and you will do the do
the do the
report moving on to House Bill
1542 relative to possession and
presentation of safe voer education
certificates chair recognizes
representative Healey
make a motion of ought to pass on this
motion of ought to pass and there is an
amendment we we have one or two
amendments well go with one you go with
one which one is the
one the this one is
07458 um I think it was emailed to
everyone um do you want me do you want
to have Bob speak first yeah uh Bob you
got a copy of this yet oh it's coming
down well first of all you who wants
to because you put in the bill do you do
you want to you want to uh make a motion
to the
amendment did we have that is this
uh
yeah I'll put in a motion for Amendment
uh to 1542 FN 2024
07458 I
okay on the amendment uh oh look is
there a
second I'll second it second by
representative Harvey
bullia is do you wish to speak on the
amendment it looks like uh on Amendment
the that we got it was uh originally had
left out that they wanted to have the
back of the original uh document which
would show the um I believe
a um barode a barcode and or some kind
of QR code or something like that so I'd
want to have that uh added to um make
sure that they have both sides with the
document
okay see wish to speak on your
second that um no that's pretty
straightforward
and
nice is there anyone else wishes to
speak on the amendment repres
representative
thank you Mr chair just I'm only saying
something because I was the one that
originally asked for the Second
Amendment um and um I spoke with
representative Harvey bolia at the
beginning of this uh I I I my Amendment
wasn't needed so that's why we're going
with the original one just want to make
it sure everyone's understands that
thank you thank you anyone else to speak
on the
amendment seeing
none Will C please call the rooll okay
yes thank you on
07458 for house Bell 1542 repres parb
yes representative GS yes representative
organ yes votes yes representative hey
yes representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative
Vil representa oh thank you um
representative Ron
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson
yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
ho yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes and
representative Malloy yes and the chair
yes 20 to Z motion
passes and motion ought to pass as
amended wish to speak on the
motion yeah this is just common sense
most people are carrying their cell
phones nowadays I'm hoping someday they
maybe they even come up with an app so
it'll make it even easier for them
because if they take a picture of it or
have an app that's what I have for my
insurance cards now I think this is just
step step
forward anyone else wish to well
speak your second no thank you okay uh
anyone else wish to speak on the ought
to pass as amended seeing none cler
please call the RO
yes ought to pass as amended
representative harb yes representative
Golds yes representative organ yes cler
votes yes representative hey yes
representative wolf
representative migu yes representative
Donell yes representative Don yes
representative Veil yes representative
rung yes representative Kelly yes
representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative
lontine representative lit yes represent
M yes and the chair yes 20 motion
passes 20 to zero motion
passes uh again consent okay and finally
chair recognized representative Veil for
House Bill
1562 pardon yes represent WR excuse me
thank you Mr chair it's not pass it's
pass my
I I move
itl on HB
1562 for a
second second by representative
Vale you wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr
chair I enjoyed a very long and
successful career in my working days
although I would call these some of
these working days and one of the
reasons for that is I got great advice
along the way and I had a boss that once
told me Rosemary you're really great at
leading a parade but look back once in a
while to see if anyone's following and
obviously with this bill I didn't have
many people following so I'd like to
just you know have the parade go off
into the sunset and uh uh we'll let this
go and enjoy the rest of the Beautiful
Day
I know a lot of windmills around that
you wish
this yes Mr chair I feel she read my
mind before she began to speak except I
didn't know the story but thank you so
much representative um rang we did have
a heated meeting down in reps Hall and
there was so many interesting facts that
came out and not only were they
interested they were terrifying and I
think there's a lot of work ahead before
we can look at something like this and I
look forward to that happening so thank
you sentive
Derby thank you Mr chair this is the
last time I'll speak today um I are
you I don't know I'll take a bet on
it I want to thank representative um
rang for bringing this bill forward
because while she might not have had
many people um behind her that's true
she um the discussion that it uh that it
caused pointed out some real
deficiencies in statute regarding
personal watercraft right now and I hope
that representative rang and I'm happy
to work with her to bring forward a
different bill that doesn't try to
change um doesn't try to restrict
watercraft in general but addresses some
of the safety concerns we heard so
thanks again representative
R anyone else seeing no one the court
please call
all on itl representative harb yes
representative gold yes representative
Horgan yes CL votes yes representative
Hy yes representative wolf yes
representative Miku yes representative
donelly yes representative dun yes
representative Vale yes representative R
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
ho yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
mooy
yes and for the final vote of the Day
represent chair
yes okay motion
passes 20 to
zero that could be the final vote of the
of the
Season
consent oh uh oh screwed up my my
numbering okay that was
20 all right all right uh
now okay all of the
um all of the blurbs you I'm supposed to
ask for the blurbs by the end of the day
I'm not going to do that they didn't say
well they said the day it's hearing but
I think maybe like the how about how
about
Sunday okay the blurbs for Sunday I they
make life a little easier what they
going to do fire
me yes the
not no no there
is
house what I don't when can we expect to
start on the Senate bills any idea uh
probably now that we are uh finished uh
this this finish them uh I would think
we would start on uh after up crossover
and crossover is only a week or so away
week or two away but you got the you got
next week off I hear they're already
hearing some of them some some are they
some people act I don't know the people
who had less than we do I think I've
already finished
so we're not we're still we're still
doing some
fighting yes Mr chair do you have any
idea how many bills we will be getting I
did see that we had maybe a handful like
five of them we had we what five you can
actually see what we there are they're
they're still Senate is not finished so
uh yeah there may be more but I think I
saw five in the list uh on the uh under
the the heading on this on the website
yeah the State website I think I saw
five but that was a week or two ago so
some more might have come
along we'll
see
anyway see you later
than
for